It's so good to be here with you guys today. It's so great to be here with you guys. It feels like it's been a while, no, it feels like it's been a while since I've said it's really good to be with you guys. It's really good to be with you guys. How are your headphones? Do they fit okay? Are they tight? My headphones?
很高兴今天能和大家在一起。能和大家在一起真是太棒了。感觉好像已经有一段时间了，不，感觉好像有一段时间我没有说过很高兴和大家在一起了。能和大家在一起真的很好。你们的耳机怎么样？它们戴着合适吗？紧不紧？我的耳机？
Yeah, for the record today. Yeah. Everything feels pretty good. Wait, wait, you've got new headphones on, don't you shiny? I do, yeah. They're new. I might wear them out. I might wear them out.
对，今天记录一下。对。一切感觉都挺好的。等等，等等，你戴着新耳机，对吧，亮晶晶的？是的，我有。它们是新的。我可能会戴着它们出门。我可能会戴着它们出门。
Why? Because you want to look like Princess Leia? Yeah, I think they look cool. Wait, wait, wait, wait. This whole thing was a setup because you wanted compliments for your new headphones? Yeah. Well, did you want to mention the company or something like that? Is that what you're angling for?
为什么？因为你想看起来像莱娅公主？对，我觉得它们看起来很酷。等等，等等，等等，等等。整件事是个局，因为你想为你的新耳机讨个夸奖？对。好吧，你想提一下公司或者类似的事情吗？你是在暗示这个吗？
I have no idea what the company is. Oh, wait, I just got a text. Welcome, it's an all-new smart list. Smart. How about I fixed myself? Guys, guys, it's about time. I know how to fix myself now. I saw you looking, I saw you looking, and then doing stuff.
我完全不知道是什么公司。哦，等等，我刚收到一条短信。欢迎，这是一个全新的SmartLess。Smart。我怎么把自己弄好了？伙计们，伙计们，是时候了。我现在知道怎么修理自己了。我看到你在看了，我看到你在看，然后做一些事情。
And I actually saw you do the class. You literally went like this. Yeah, tap the lips. That's how the brain works. Audibly went. It's a button on the lips. By the way, J.B., you have ruined forever. I noticed it yesterday again.
而且我真的看到你做那个动作了。你字面意义上是这样的。对，点一下嘴唇。大脑就是这样运作的。发出了声音。嘴唇上有一个按钮。顺便说一句，JB，你彻底毁了。我昨天又注意到了。
And somebody commented on it, getting out of the car, I went, hui! Yeah. It tightens the core to make a little noise. Sean, do you do it now, too? I do it when I get in the car, too. He'll go, hui. Hei.
然后有人对此发表了评论，下车时，我发出：呼！对。发出一点声音可以收紧核心。肖恩，你现在也这么做吗？我上车时也会这样做。他会发出：呼。嘿。
I realize I've been doing it since I was 35 because of you. We're all getting that old. Yeah. Yeah, so, well, this is, what number episode is this for us? We're north of 200, right? Ben and Rob, anybody? Over 250, I think. Yeah, we're in the two 80s now.
我意识到因为你，我从35岁就开始这么做了。我们都变得那么老了。对。对，那么，这是，这是我们的第几集？我们已经超过200集了，对吧？本和鲁本，有人知道吗？超过250集，我想。对，我们现在快到280集了。
I can, no, really? I can now, I'm basically my own tech support now. I can, I know how to find the little... We don't need to tell you 290 times. You know, that's the good news. It is true. Out of the three of us, who has the most technical problems? Who gets, do we get to vote, or do you have to own up to?
我能，不，真的吗？我现在可以，我基本上是我自己的技术支持了。我能，我知道怎么找到那个小……我们不需要告诉你290遍。你知道，这是好消息。确实如此。我们三个人中，谁的技术问题最多？谁遇到，我们可以投票，还是你得自己承认？
I think I'm all right. I'll bet, I'll bet, Sean, you're worse because, you're able to because Scotty can catch you every time you find. I scream my head off if I'm like, I can't log on. Who has the least? The least problems? Yeah, technical. Tech problems.
我觉得我还行。我敢打赌，我敢打赌，肖恩，你更糟糕，因为，你能够，因为斯科蒂每次都能抓到你。如果我大喊大叫，比如，我登录不上。谁的问题最少？最少的问题？对，技术。技术问题。
Not problems. Not world problems. No, it's always you. Why is that? Because that's what you do for a living. Well, more probably used to the setup of the mic. Yeah, isn't that nice? That's sweet.
不是问题。不是世界问题。不，总是你。为什么会这样？因为那是你谋生的手段。嗯，可能更习惯话筒的设置了。对，不是很棒吗？真贴心。
Well, and you also, you started, weren't you one of the original geek squad guys? I did do. I did. I still own the next. name what is it yeah yeah i still i did all the art i went to a dodgers game with jason a couple weeks ago you sure did and then we went to the u sc football game yeah you did and you had a decent we had a decent quarter there well yeah that was crazy we jason and i i had all the concessions that jason i was holding this guy looked like he was at a state fair yeah fuck it did it looked like i had like
嗯，而且你还，你开始的时候，你不是极客小分队（Geek Squad）的元老之一吗？我的确做过。我做过。我依然拥有下一个。名字叫什么，对，对，对，我还拥有，我做过所有的艺术，几个星期前我和杰森一起去看了道奇队的比赛，你确实去了，然后我们去了南加州大学的橄榄球比赛，对，你去了，而且你有一个不错的，我们在那里度过了不错的一节，哦，对，那太疯狂了，杰森和我，我拿了杰森所有的零食，我拿着那个家伙看起来像在州集市一样，对，操，确实是，看起来我有，
old bessie had and two armfuls I had like a soft pretzel And Jason has a hot dog And his phone And I had all the drinks in the pretzels And the cheese dipping song I once described you as a soft pretzel That's funny
老贝茜有两个满怀。我拿了一个软椒盐卷饼，杰森拿了一个热狗，还有他的手机。我拿着所有的饮料、椒盐卷饼和奶酪蘸酱。我曾经把你形容为一个软椒盐卷饼。那很有趣。
Just a knots all over Yeah But it sounds like you really live In your best life though But that was so embarrassing That was so fun But it was so embarrassing Because we somebody was in our seats
到处都是结。对。但听起来你确实在过着你最好的生活。但那太尴尬了。那太有趣了。但那太尴尬了，因为有人坐在我们的座位上。
And then I felt like the whole stadium Was looking at us as we were just standing Yeah so you know You know you show up a little bit late And people spread out And they get in your seats and then you have to like, you have to, you show up at the aisle, and you're kind of in a half squat
然后我觉得整个体育场都在看着我们，而我们只是站着。所以你知道，你知道你稍微迟到了 一会儿，人们散开了，他们占了你的座位，然后你不得不，你得，你出现在过道上，你有点半蹲着，
because you don't want to, like, block the line behind you. And here come these big, these big dickhead actor. With all our groceries. Yeah. Totally. Right. And there was like, oh, you're going to kick these people out. I know.
因为你不想挡住你后面的队伍。然后这些大人物，这些混蛋演员来了。带着我们所有的零食。对。完全是。对。然后就像，哦，你要把这些人赶走。我知道。
But you have to, like, show proof of your tickets. And you remember, you used to pass your ticket down the aisle. It's so embarrassing. But now the tickets are on your phone. I used to love you. Tickets are on your phone. You got to, like, pass your phone down the end up. People are touching your phone.
但你必须，出示你的票据证明。你还记得，你以前把票传过过道。太尴尬了。但现在票都在你的手机上。我以前很喜欢。票都在你的手机上。你得，把你的手机传到尽头。人们在碰你的手机。
You know, I don't like that, Willie. Right. And these guys, guess what? Here's the news. While he's eating his hot dog. Yeah, they wouldn't move. Yeah. No.
你知道，我可不喜欢那样，威利。对。而这些家伙，你猜怎么着？消息来了。当他在吃热狗的时候。对，他们就是不肯挪窝。对。没有。
They're like, yeah, I see this as your ticket, but they told us to sit here. I'm like, who told you to sit? The usher. I said, well, I don't see the usher now. Well, you got to get them and tell them to move us. That's right. And then I'm so we had to sit on the stairs with our groceries and wait. I mean, oh, God, it was the word.
他们说，是的，我看到这是你的票，但他们叫我们坐这儿的。我说，谁叫你们坐这儿的？领座员。我说，那我现在看不到领座员了。好吧，你得去找他们，叫他们把我们移开。没错。然后我，所以我们不得不带着零食坐在楼梯上等待。我的意思是，哦，天哪，太糟糕了。
It took like 10 minutes. And then they finally got them out. And then they finally got out. Did it come to blows? Did it almost come to blows? A family of four were relocated. And just us two sat down And now we got two extra seats next to us
花了大概10分钟。然后他们终于把他们弄走了。然后他们终于出来了。动起手来了吗？差点动起手来吗？一家四口被重新安置了。只有我们两个坐下了。现在我们旁边多了两个空位。
And we looked like super assholes And I ate my pretzel on the stairs And my cheese went everywhere Oh no You mean actual cheese Yeah It wasn't a result of eating the pretzel Made your cheese go everywhere
我们看起来像超级混蛋。我在楼梯上吃我的椒盐卷饼，我的奶酪到处都是。哦，不。你是说真正的奶酪？对。这不是吃椒盐卷饼导致你的奶酪到处都是。
You created cheese No Okay We'll save that for Smartless after dark Which we still haven't gotten off the ground But I'm still working on the logo Which is funny because our guest today I said Smartless
你创造了奶酪？不。好吧，我们把它留给《SmartLess Dark》，我们还没能正式推出它，但我还在设计标志。这很有趣，因为我们今天的嘉宾，我说SmartLess，
He often refers to it as shameless And I know he's joking in his tongue and cheek Because I love him It is pretty shameless It is and this is a guy who is really You want to talk about live the life This guy's really lived the life Okay
他经常把这叫作“不知羞耻”（Shameless），我知道他是开玩笑，因为我爱他。这确实挺无耻的。确实如此，而这家伙真的是，你想谈论体验生活，这家伙真的是体验过生活，好吧。
Oh boy He starts out He's the pride of Connecticut Sort of He started out running a clothing company Out of Afghanistan and India No joke Back in like the early 70s
哦，天哪。他从……他是康涅狄格州的骄傲。差不多吧。他最初在阿富汗和印度经营一家服装公司。说真的。大概在70年代初。
When nobody was over there He just I mean he's the kind of guy You'd find him on a night boat to Tangier That's the kind of duty he is Out of nowhere He comes back after running, literally trying to avoid tariffs
那时根本没人去那里。他，我的意思是他是那种，你会在去丹吉尔的夜船上找到他的人。他就是那种责任心强的人。毫无预兆地，他回来了，在经历了一番经营，字面意义上为了逃避关税，
and running clothing illegally across the St. Loris into upstate New York. He then decides he's going to change everything, and he goes and he starts to create, he creates this thing that literally changed the way that we saw, music, fashion, culture, everything, it went global, everywhere. He runs a bunch of little networks
把衣服非法走私过圣劳伦斯河进入纽约州北部。然后他决定改变一切，他去创造，他创造了这个东西，它字面意义上改变了我们看待音乐、时尚、文化、一切的方式，它走向了全球，无处不在。他经营着一堆小网络，
that you might have heard of called Nickelodeon VH1 Comedy Central. Oh, this is old Mr. Tom Preston. He becomes CEO of Viacom, and now he's the chair of the one campaign fighting poverty. He's done it all. He's the coolest guy, and I'm happy to call him, my friend. You guys, it's Mr. Tom Freston.
你可能听说过，叫作尼克国际儿童频道（Nickelodeon）、VH1、喜剧中心（Comedy Central）。哦，这就是老汤姆·弗雷斯顿（Tom Freston）。他成了维亚康姆（Viacom）的首席执行官，现在他是消除贫困的“同一个运动”（ONE Campaign）的主席。他什么都做过。他是最酷的家伙，我很高兴称他为我的朋友。伙计们，这就是汤姆·弗雷斯顿先生。
Cannot wait. Oh, Mr. Hey, guys. I can't wait to hear all about this fella. It's an honor to be here. Here on Shameless? You've seen all 10 seasons on Showtime for us? Shameless.
迫不及待了。哦，先生。嗨，伙计们。我迫不及待地想听听这个家伙的一切了。很荣幸能来到这里。在这里参加《Shameless》？你看过我们在Showtime上的全部10季了吗？《Shameless》。
Shameless. Welcome to the show. Wait, how do you and Will know each other, Tom? Just for hanging around in New York, out on Long Island. Oh, yeah. We originally met through our mutual friend many years ago through Jimmy Buffett back, Jimmy and Jane Buffett introduced us back in the day.
《Shameless》。欢迎来到节目。等等，你和威利是怎么认识的，汤姆？只是在纽约长岛闲逛时认识的。哦，是的。我们最初很多年前通过共同的朋友认识的，通过吉米·巴菲特（Jimmy Buffett），当年吉米和简·巴菲特（Jane Buffett）把我们介绍认识的。
Tom's good friend, may you rest in peace. Yeah, I'm sorry about your loss there. The great Jimmy Buffett. And who was, Jimmy, one of the things he did was he brought a lot of people together and introduced a lot of people. Am I right about that, Tom? Yeah, he sure did. Yeah, he was just...
汤姆的好朋友，愿他安息。是的，对于你的损失我感到很遗憾。伟大的吉米·巴菲特。吉米做过的一件事，就是把很多人聚在一起，介绍了很多认识的人。我说的对吗，汤姆？是的，他确实这么做了。是的，他就是……
Tom, how'd you meet Jimmy? I met Jimmy in the basement of a bar called J.P. in Manhattan, in the 70s, it was like, you know, at 5 a.m., you'd open up one of those Bilko doors or 8 a.m. and walk out in the sunlight like a vampire. But he would hang out there. It was like sort of a music industry hang out. So I met him there in 1977. Wow. And we just, you know, would hang out and trips. I would travel with him a lot. He'd like to go to, he liked to travel. And that was especially good, especially after he bought a jet.
汤姆，你是怎么认识吉米的？我在曼哈顿一家叫JP的酒吧地下室认识吉米的，那是70年代，你知道的，早上5点，你会推开那些比尔科（Bilko）舱门，或者早上8点，像吸血鬼一样走到阳光下。但他会常在那里闲逛。那有点像是音乐界的人聚集的地方。所以我在1977年在那儿认识了他。哇。然后我们只是，你知道，会一起闲逛和旅行。我经常跟他一起旅行。他喜欢去，他喜欢旅行。这特别好，特别是他买了一架喷气式飞机之后。
Yeah, was he flying planes? back then? Yeah, he could fly all kinds of planes. The Jimmy Jets. Yeah, he was very serious about it. He could fly sea planes, you know, all kinds of big fancy ones as well. And Tom, he had a few, Jimmy also crashed a few planes. He did.
是啊，他那时候在开飞机吗？是的，他会开各种飞机。吉米喷气机。是的，他对此非常认真。他会开水上飞机，你知道，各种高级的大飞机。汤姆，他有过几次，吉米也坠毁过几架飞机。他确实有过。
He landed in Nantuckin and sort of flipped it over. And that was one. And there was other instances of Mountheasans. One time when we were, I told that story when they did that, that show at the Hollywood Bowl in honor of Jimmy and I told the story about he was going to do takeoff and landings on this little island
他在楠塔基特岛（Nantucket）降落时把飞机翻了过来。那是其中一次。还有其他好几次。有一次我们，我在好莱坞碗（Hollywood Bowl）为纪念吉米举办的那场演出上讲过那个故事，我讲了他打算在那个小岛上做起飞和降落的故事，
and he said, I said, what are you doing this morning? He goes, I got to go get certified. I'm doing takeoffs and landings. Do you want to go? And I go, yeah. And then he left the room and Jane turned him and she goes, dude, he's crashed like three planes. You're not getting on it. Oh my God. The key word there is training. Do you want to come for training? No.
他说，我问，你今天早上在干嘛？他说，我要去拿认证。我在做起飞和降落。你想去吗？我说，行。然后他离开了房间，简转过身对我说，老兄，他已经坠毁了大约三架飞机了。你可别上去。哦，天哪。关键词是训练。你想来参加训练吗？不。
So, Tom, I want to go I want to go all the way back. By the way, Tom's got a book that we're going to get into Tom's book in a second because I read it a while ago and it's phenomenal. But I Will is called Unplugged, which is fantastic, which is I think out now, right, Tom? It comes out November 18. Yeah.
所以，汤姆，我想回到，我想一路回到……顺便说一句，汤姆写了一本书，我们一会儿要讲到汤姆的书，因为我前段时间读过了，非常棒。我读的是威利的那本叫《Unplugged》，太棒了，我想现在已经出版了吧，汤姆？它将于11月18日出版。是的。
So, but, you know, again, we've known each other a little bit over the years, but I read your book. So Tom, walk us through, and I wasn't joking when I said, you started a clothing company in Afghanistan and India. Yeah, I want to know how and why. 1970. How is one able to do that? Well, let's see. I had been working in an ad agency in New York. I got assigned to Charmin toilet paper.
所以，但是，你知道，再次说明，我们这些年彼此了解一点，但我读了你的书。所以，汤姆，带我们回顾一下，当我说是你在阿富汗和印度开了一家服装公司时，我可不是在开玩笑。是的，我想知道怎么回事以及为什么。1970年。一个人怎么能做到这一点？好吧，让我想想。我曾在纽约的一家广告公司工作。我被分配到了查曼（Charmin）卫生纸。
Sure. A tough account. Working with Mr. Whipple. And my old girlfriend was in Paris call me. I said, hey, you can't do that. Come with me. We're going to cross the Sahara Desert. And I quit my job. And a week later, I was on a plane. And I met her, and we traveled around and then she left and I kept going I tried for a whole year and that at one point I I met some woman who said you know you've got to go to India that's the greatest show on earth so I did do that I and I ended up loving India and Afghanistan and I stayed for I've tried to figure out how can I live here this is like living a whole other on a whole other planet back man and what yearish this is 1972 so I stayed through 1970s
当然。一个艰难的客户。与惠普尔先生（Mr. Whipple）一起工作。我的前女友在巴黎给我打电话。我说，嘿，你不能那样做。跟我来。我们要横穿撒哈拉沙漠。我辞掉了工作。一周后，我就坐上了飞机。我遇到了她，我们一起旅行，然后她离开了，我继续走。我坚持了一整年，在那期间我遇到一个女人，她说，你知道，你得去印度，那是地球上最伟大的秀。所以我真的去了，我最后爱上了印度和阿富汗，我待了，我试图弄清楚我怎么能在这里生活，这就像生活在另一个星球上，兄弟。那是哪一年？那是1972年，所以我在那里待到了70年代。
I started a couple of businesses. We would design and make clothes. I mean, higher quality clothes we'd sell to Bloomingdale's and so forth. And it became a big business. I mean, and I had a house in Delhi, and I was able to travel everywhere. I was living like a pasha. It was wonderful. And then a bunch of bad things happened to me.
我创办了几家企业。我们设计并制作衣服。我的意思是，我们将更高质量的衣服卖给布鲁明戴尔百货公司（Bloomingdale's）等等。它成了一项大生意。我的意思是，我在德里有一所房子，我可以去任何地方旅行。我过着帕夏（Pasha）一样的生活。太棒了。然后一堆糟糕的事情发生在我身上。
And not the least of which was Jimmy Carter put an embargo. It's sort of like what's going on today with the tariffs. There would be no more clothing imports from India. And I had all this stuff in production. Wow. You know, it's a nightmare working there in those days. So I actually ended up smuggling three tons of stuff in from Canada. Yeah, wait, wait, Tom, take us through that.
其中最糟糕的是吉米·卡特（Jimmy Carter）实施了禁运。这有点像今天发生的关税问题。不再有来自印度的服装进口了。而我所有的东西都正在生产中。哇。你知道，在那日子里在那里工作简直是一场噩梦。所以我最终不得不从加拿大走私了三吨货物进来。是的，等等，等等，汤姆，带我们了解一下。
So you get, by the way, this is like, so this before, obviously, before the Internet and all that stuff. So you guys, this is all sort of phone calls and everything takes a little bit longer. and now you've got all these goods that you're sitting on, and you've got to get it into the States. And so you decide what? Well, I had met in my years there all these smugglers, you know, sort of rife with drug smugglers, and they would always say how easy it was to smuggle stuff into the United States.
所以你，顺便说一句，这就像是，这显然是在互联网出现之前以及所有这些事情之前。所以伙计们，这全都是靠打电话，而且每件事都要花更长的时间。现在你手里积压了所有这些货物，你得把它们运进美国。所以你决定怎么办？好吧，我在那里的几年里遇到了所有的走私犯，你知道，到处都是毒品走私犯，他们总是说把东西走私进美国是多么容易。
Wow. Just by putting it on a plane and just nobody checking? Well, no, they had, they would send stuff in shipments. Yeah. They would take stuff across borders. But in this case, I was allowed to bring stuff legally into Canada. And, you know, I figured, you know, if these long-haired goofballs could do it, I could do it.
哇。只要把它放在飞机上，就没人检查？不，不，他们有，他们会分批发送货物。是的。他们会把东西运过边境。但在这种情况下，我被允许合法地把东西带进加拿大。而且，你知道，我想，如果这些长发笨蛋能做到，我也能做到。
And I felt like I wasn't really committing a crime. It was really foolish, I would admit, I mean. But I just want to get some money back. I felt I had really been ripped off by the government with no prior announcement or anything. So that was the end of my business. And I also had my business in Afghanistan kind of vaporized because there have been a communist coup.
我觉得我并不是真的在犯罪。我得承认，这真的很愚蠢，我的意思是。但我只是想拿回一些钱。我觉得我被政府敲诈了，没有任何事先通知或其他什么。所以这就是我生意的结束。我在阿富汗的生意也因为发生了一场共产主义政变而烟消云散了。
there right but tom can you can you for for a for a real soft uh hollywood idiot like me uh who any this whole thing sounds just so foreign from anything i would ever imagine let alone pursue he won't go east of lebraia put it right way okay just forget it or or south of the of the airport What was your life like at that age, at that time that gave you either the courage to have this wanderlust or maybe the opposite of courage? There was just stuff happening in your life. It was like, fuck all this. I just want to go to the end of the earth for something completely new, something completely different because this ain't working. Was it one of the two?
在那里，对吧？但是汤姆，你能否，对于像我这样一个真正的软弱的好莱坞白痴来说，对我而言，这一切听起来与我能想象的任何事情都格格不入，更不用说去追求了，他绝不去莱布雷亚（La Brea）以东的地方，把它说清楚，好吧，算了吧，或者机场以南的地方。你那个年纪、那个时代的生活是怎样的，给了你那种去流浪的勇气，或者也许是相反的勇气？你的生活中发生了某些事情。就像是，去他的这一切。我只想去世界的尽头寻找全新的、完全不同的东西，因为这根本不管用。是这两者之一吗？
Yeah, it was more the latter. I mean, I was, yeah, it was the 60s, so, you know, there was a lot of alienation around. Freedom sounded like a good option. I decided early on I didn't want to really have a mainstream kind of life. I had taken a year off and sort of bartended around. But you had got in your MBA, right? Yeah, I had an MBA. I did that.
是的，更像是后者。我的意思是，我当时是，是的，那是60年代，所以，你知道，周围有很多疏离感。自由听起来是个不错的选择。我早早就决定我不想过那种主流的生活。我请了一年假，到处当调酒师。但你拿到了MBA学位，对吧？对，我有一个MBA。我拿到了。
That was a way to stay out of the draft in those days. Right. And then, so it was, I just wanted to sort of leave out of the mainstream life, and it sounded very exotic and interesting. to be living in a place so foreign. What was it about the mainstream life that just didn't feel something that you were attracted to, especially given the fact that you had gone down this road of mainstream?
那是当年逃避兵役的一种方式。对。然后，所以它是，我只是想离开主流生活，在一个如此陌生的地方生活听起来非常异国情调和有趣。主流生活的什么地方让你觉得没有吸引力，特别是考虑到你已经走上了这条主流道路？
You got an MBA, and like you're set, you're ready. You put a huge time and financial investment into the mainstream, and then you said, yeah, no, let's flip it, let's go 180 this way. It wasn't fun. Have you ever tried selling toilet paper? And before that, I was on the G.I. Joe account, which was like, you know, the war toy of the military industrial complex. It was a very alienated time. A lot of people were quitting jobs and sort of trying to go off and do their own thing. So everything looked appealing. Everything looked appealing and it looked really exciting because I wasn't having any fun.
你拿到了MBA，你本可以一切就绪，准备好了。你对主流投入了巨大的时间和资金，然后你说，好吧，不，我们反过来，我们180度大转弯。这不好玩。你试过卖卫生纸吗？在此之前，我在G.I. Joe（特种部队）的账号上工作，那就像是，你知道的，军工复合体的战争玩具。那是一个非常疏离的时代。很多人都在辞职，试图离开并做他们自己的事情。所以一切看起来都很有吸引力。一切看起来都很有吸引力，而且看起来非常令人兴奋，因为我一点也不开心。
I felt like I needed to stretch out a bit. I'd been in school for like 18 years or something. So I was ready to go. And then I fell in love with this very foreign place. And in those days, it was really foreign, you know. Also age, because if you're young, you're like, well, I might as well try it now. I was 25, 26, you know. I mean, a young, so if not now, when. That's, yeah.
我觉得我需要舒展一下筋骨。我在学校呆了大约18年左右。所以我准备好出发了。然后我爱上了这个非常陌生的地方。在那些日子里，它真的很陌生，你知道。还有年龄，因为如果你年轻，你会想，我何不现在就试试。我当时25、26岁，你知道的。我的意思是，很年轻，此时不试更待何时。那是，是的。
Yeah, I remember you sort of describe in the book when you first get to Morocco, when you're still with your traveling with your friend, your girlfriend, and just like meeting these people and they're all on the beach, like people you had met along the way and you were like, look at this life, everybody's, nobody's kind of, everybody's just kind of doing whatever they want a little bit, right? And it kind of, that opened your eyes to it. It sounds so good, right?
是的，我记得你在书中描述过，当你刚到摩洛哥时，当时你还在和你的朋友、你的女友一起旅行，遇到这些人，他们都在海滩上，就像你在路上遇到的人一样，你当时想，看看这生活，每个人，没有谁，每个人都只是随心所欲地做他们想做的事，对吧？这有点，这让你大开眼界。听起来太棒了，对吧？
Yeah, there was a bit of a phenomenon they called it the hippie trail. I mean, no one self-identified as a hippie, but like in California, New York, people were, in those days, if you wanted to drop out, you sort of went to a commune in a cold place in Northern California or somewhere upstate New York. But in Europe, people would head south, you know, to Morocco or India or Lebanon and, you know, kind of like see how long they could travel.
是的，当时有一种被称为嬉皮士小径（hippie trail）的现象。我的意思是，没有人自称为嬉皮士，但在加利福尼亚、纽约，人们，在那些日子里，如果你想隐退，你通常会去北加州或纽约州北部某个寒冷地方的公社。但在欧洲，人们会向南走，你知道，去摩洛哥、印度或黎巴嫩，然后，你知道，看看他们能旅行多久。
I'd meet people who travel for years. Well, that sounds like a really sort of contributing factor, that it was more so in society then than it is, I think, today. More commonplace for folks to just, you know, pick up and get out and explore a bunch of different corners for a few years and then presumably maybe come back and reenter mainstream. Yeah, was that a bit more? part of the culture than it is today?
我会遇到旅行多年的人。嗯，这听起来像是一个非常重要的促成因素，当时社会上这种现象比现在要普遍得多。对于人们来说，收拾行囊，出去探索不同的角落几年，然后大概再回来重新融入主流，是一件更司空见惯的事。是的，那是比现在更普遍吗？
Yeah, you know, I think the world could use a little bit more of that today. You see, these kids are so anxious, and they go to school, and they're having panic attacks, and they're being... You've got to get out, and you've got to immediately start providing and accomplishing. I meet these kids. They say, I'm graduating from college, I'm starting work on Monday. Right. Starting my career on Monday.
是的，你知道，我觉得今天的世界更需要多一点那种精神。你看，现在的孩子们太焦虑了，他们去上学，他们有恐慌症，他们正在……你得走出去，你得立刻开始提供价值和取得成就。我遇到这些孩子们。他们说，我大学毕业了，我周一就要开始工作。对。周一就开始我的职业生涯。
So we'll take a break. Right. You know, the world's like the best educator out there traveling around. Out of curiosity, Tom, do you give that, did you impart that on your own? sons just, you know, as much as you're comfortable with talking about? Oh, yeah, I do. I encourage them to. They've become, both of them have become good travelers, and they're very comfortable, you know, going anywhere, making their own plans and really proud of them in that regard. Did you notice a big change when they came back?
所以我们要休息一下。对。你知道，世界就像外面最好的教育家，到处旅行。出于好奇，汤姆，你会把这个传授给你的儿子们吗？只要你在谈论这个时感到舒适？哦，是的，我会的。我鼓励他们这样做。他们已经成为了，他们俩都成了优秀的旅行者，他们非常适应，你知道的，去任何地方，自己做计划，在这方面我为他们感到非常骄傲。你注意到他们回来后有什么大变化吗？
Well, they didn't go like, I mean, I traveled for a couple of years. They really, you know, would take, actually my oldest son, he kind of went to work almost right away, but they, none of them have really made extensive trips like I had. they're more caught up in this time go back to the to the canada so did you end up bringing those clothes and all those goods into the u.s or no it was so easy you just but you did it yourself though tom well i enlisted a guy i knew in canada whose father used to be like a rum runner and uh he was ready for another trail another trick wow it's like smoking the bandit you came on the boat with the stuff yourself though Yeah, yeah. So, you know, you go through the thousand islands.
嗯，他们没有像那样，我的意思是，我旅行了几年。他们真的，你知道，会花时间，实际上我的大儿子，他几乎马上就开始工作了，但是他们，没有人像我那样进行过长途旅行。他们更多地被困在这个时代……回到加拿大，所以你最后把那些衣服和所有的货物带进美国了吗？或者没有？太简单了，你只是，但那是你自己做的，汤姆？好吧，我在加拿大招募了一个我认识的家伙，他的父亲以前是个走私私酒的人，他已经准备好迎接另一条路线、另一个把戏了。哇，这就像《横冲直撞大逃亡》（Smokey and the Bandit），你自己带着东西上了船？对，对。所以，你知道，你要穿过千岛群岛。
There's all these islands, and, you know, then no one knows where the border is really. Right. And there's boats floating around. No one knows who's who. And ice wasn't around. Right, right, right. Did you end up learning any of the languages over there?
那里有所有的岛屿，你知道，然后没有人真正知道边界在哪里。对。而且有很多船只在漂浮。没有人知道谁是谁。冰块不在附近。对，对，对。你最后学会那里的任何语言了吗？
In India, you get pretty spoiled because people speak English a lot. Yeah, it was a British occupation. But I mean, I could move my way around in Hindi. But in Afghanistan, I picked up a fair amount of Farsi, which is the language. I mean, Adar. They call it's a dialect of Farsi. I could get myself around the bazaars and, you know, order food and take taxis. Do you retain it now?
在印度，你会被宠坏，因为人们经常说英语。是的，那是英国占领地。但我的意思是，我可以用印地语应付。但在阿富汗，我学会了相当多的波斯语，也就是那种语言。我的意思是，阿达（Adar）。他们称它为波斯语的一种方言。我可以在集市上应付，你知道，点食物和坐出租车。你现在还保留着吗？
Not so much. Yeah. Not so much. Wait, so Tom, so actually, this is a good, you go out there because you've got this, as Jason called this wanderluss or this desire to get out in the world and we talk, but there's not enough of that, but you kind of bring a little bit, you leave on the sort of, because you've come, you don't have a great corporate experience in that. You're working on Charmin and G.
没那么多了。是的。没那么多了。等等，所以汤姆，实际上，这是一个很好的例子，你到外面去，因为你有着，正如杰森所说的这种流浪癖或探索世界的渴望，我们讨论过，虽然这种精神还不够，但你带回了一点，你离开了那类，因为你已经来了，你在那方面没有很好的企业经验。你在查曼和G...
like fuck all this you go out into the world and you come back and you kind of bring a little bit of that rebel attitude with you as you because you re-enter into a corporate environment a little bit but you bring a little bit of that sort of that rebellious nature into what you do you start to work on pretty immediately on MTV and can you talk to us how I mean it's like a perfect you're the perfect guy for that because you you were bringing that rebel spirit into the corporate world Well, you know, I really loved traveling and being over there. And when I came back, I was, like, wiped out of that life. What else do I really love?
去他的这一切，你走向世界，你回来了，当你重新进入公司环境时，你身上带着一点那种叛逆的态度，你把那种叛逆的本性带入了你所做的事情中，你几乎立刻就开始在MTV工作，你能跟我们谈谈你是如何，我的意思是，这就像是一个完美的，你是那类工作的完美人选，因为你把那种叛逆的精神带入了企业世界。好吧，你知道，我真的很喜欢旅行和在那里的生活。当我回来的时候，我，就像是，与那种生活脱节了。我还真正喜欢什么？
Well, I was really, I was a major fanatic about music and rock and roll. Good time for it. I was caught an article in Billboard magazine. I started studying where could I get a job? And there was a guy who said, you know, we're going to start a video music channel. That's going to be the cable, the TV revolution is starting. And they had already started Nickelodeon. And they had a thing called a movie channel.
嗯，我真的，我是音乐和摇滚乐的超级狂热分子。好时候。我在《公告牌》杂志上看到了一篇文章。我开始研究我在哪里可以找到工作。有个家伙说，你知道，我们要创办一个视频音乐频道。那将是，电视革命即将开始。他们已经创办了尼克国际儿童频道（Nickelodeon）。他们还有一个叫电影频道（The Movie Channel）的东西。
So I got an interview. My brother knew a guy who had just gone to work there. So I got an interview when I made this case. And finally, there was a guy named Bob Pittman. Yeah. Who I was in like 32 at the time. And the interview was with what company? This is called, then it was called Warner Amex Satellite Entertainment Company.
所以我去面试了。我哥哥认识一个刚去那里工作的人。所以我得到了一个面试机会，我提出了我的理由。最后，有一个叫鲍勃·皮特曼（Bob Pittman）的家伙。是的。我当时大约32岁。面试是跟哪家公司进行的？这叫作，当时叫作华纳美国运通卫星娱乐公司（Warner Amex Satellite Entertainment Company）。
Wow. Doesn't roll off the time. It was a joint venture of Warner and American Express. Yeah, wow. So this guy Bob Pittman, who was 26. never bothered going to college he was a big star they call him the long-haired one-eyed hippie and he programmed these radio stations like with don i miss him he would have got along with my mom my mom had one-home anyway he i interviewed him i said i'm your guy they said well first thing
哇。读起来真拗口。这是华纳和美国运通的合资企业。是的，哇。所以这个叫鲍勃·皮特曼的家伙，他当时26岁。从没费心去上过大学。他是个大明星，他们叫他长发独眼嬉皮士，他像唐·伊穆斯（Don Imus）那样给这些广播电台编程，他会和我妈妈很合得来，我妈妈有一个……不管怎样，我面试了他，我说我就是你要找的人。他们说，好吧，第一件事
we're looking for people with no experience in television that those were almost like the magic words i said well sure they didn't even have television where i've been living the last eight years so and I'm a music fanatic, and you're looking for entrepreneurs, and I know business, and blah, blah, blah. And then he goes, you were a hashy smuggler, weren't you? I go, not really. And he goes, not really. That means you were.
我们在寻找没有电视经验的人。那几乎就像是魔咒。我说，当然，我过去八年生活的地方甚至连电视都没有，所以我是一个音乐狂人，而你们在寻找企业家，我懂商业，巴拉巴拉。然后他说，你以前是个大麻走私犯吧？我说，不算吧。他说，不算吧。那意味着你曾经是。
So you're hired. So I got a job on this initial team that started MTV. And who was that team? It was you and Bob Pittman and you. Me and Bob Pittman, there was a guy named John Sykes. there was a guy name Oh boy John Sykes
所以你被录用了。于是我得到了这份工作，加入了最初创立MTV的团队。那个团队都有谁？是你和鲍勃·皮特曼，还有你。我和鲍勃·皮特曼，有一个叫约翰·赛克斯（John Sykes）的家伙。有一个叫……哦，天哪，约翰·赛克斯。
Steve Casey Who else was there Carolyn Baker Sue Steinberg And there was about six or seven of us Fred Seiberd Who was like Really sort of the creative genius
史蒂夫·凯西（Steve Casey）。还有谁？卡罗琳·贝克（Caroline Baker）、苏·斯坦伯格（Sue Steinberg）。大约有六七个人。弗雷德·塞伯特（Fred Seibert）是那种
Of the group And you know We were said You know get this thing On the year by August 1st We had like eight months To put this whole channel together So
团队里的创意天才。你知道，我们被告知，你知道，要在8月1日前把这个节目搬上荧幕。我们只有大约八个月的时间来把整个频道组装起来。
Wow And we will be right back and now back to the show did music videos were they already kind of happening on other platforms or somewhere and that's why you knew it would work or no there was really very little
哇。我们马上回来，现在回到节目。音乐录影带（MV）当时已经在其他平台或其他地方出现了吗？所以你才知道它会行得通？还是没有？其实很少有人
awareness about music videos in the states they existed in europe because the radio stations there were still really regulated didn't play any music so the record companies there would make these videos and you could see them like in records stores or they would put them on top of the pops on the you know on the BBC so but American I I at one summer I had a girlfriend in Berlin I remember
在美国对音乐录影带有所了解。它们在欧洲存在，因为那里的广播电台仍然受到严格管制，不播放任何音乐，所以那里的唱片公司会制作这些视频，你可以在唱片店里看到它们，或者他们会把它们放在BBC的《流行音乐排行榜》（Top of the Pops）上。但美国，我，我有年夏天在柏林有个女友，我记得
just going to her she would work I go to a record store and just watch music videos all day it's one of those kind of days I was like thinking this is like a video wonderland so I I said this is you know people are going to like this sort of build it and they will come kind of thing you guys were the egg and then the chicken came along or vice versa and and like Like those early videos, the early one, like, remember, like Frankie killed the radio star. Was the first one. Frankie goes to Hollywood. And I feel like Dyer Straits had one of the early ones, too.
去她那里，她去上班，我一整天都在唱片店里看音乐录影带。那是那种日子之一，我当时想，这就像是一个视频仙境。所以我说，你知道的，人们会喜欢这种“你建好了，他们就会来”的东西。你们是鸡蛋，然后鸡出现了，或者反过来。就像那些早期的视频，早期的那个，比如，记得吗，雷迪奥明星杀死了弗兰基（Video Killed the Radio Star）。那是第一个。弗兰基去好莱坞（Frankie Goes to Hollywood）。我觉得险峻海峡（Dire Straits）也有一个早期的。
Dyer Straits had a bunch of early ones. Yeah. Called Skateaway. Well, I was going to get into Dyer Strait because it's actually, it's a big part of the book. Jay, that's a really good point. First of all, video killed the radio star was the first video you guys aired, right, when you first launch. Is that true? Yeah.
险峻海峡有很多早期的。是的，叫《滑冰》（Skateaway）。嗯，我正要讲险峻海峡，因为实际上，这是书中的很大一部分。杰、说得太好了。首先，你们播出的第一个录影带就是《Video Killed the Radio Star》，对吧，当你们刚开播的时候？是这样的吗？是的。
Yeah. And, yeah. And you guys also, you started this thing, but I've heard stories from you and from Sykes that like you guys had like a basically like a one, like a closet with like a phone with like call waiting on it, right? You guys, it wasn't a big operation. That's called the Cheapeskates second line.
是的。而且，是的。你们也，你们创办了这个东西，但我听你和赛克斯说过，你们基本上就像有一个，像一个衣橱，里面有一部带呼叫等待功能的电话，对吧？你们，这不是一个大运营。那叫“吝啬鬼专线”（Cheapeskate's second line）。
Yeah. So then you guys started this. And then you, but then Dyer Straits had, they gave you guys the gift of all gifts because it was Mark Knopfler from what I understand and what I've read, wrote that as a sort of almost like a rebuttal to the sort of music video and the corporatization of music and all that. Is that right?
所以你们创办了这个。然后你们，接着你们，但险峻海峡给了你们一份厚礼中的厚礼，因为据我所理解和阅读的，那是马克·诺弗勒（Mark Knopfler）写的，作为对音乐录影带、音乐商业化等等现象的一种近乎反驳的回应。是这样吗？
Money for nothing, yeah. It was all about our vapidity that we were vapid. Yeah, and yet the line in that that really sold you guys was, I want my MTV. Yeah, yeah, yeah. We had Sting it, and in those days, you know, those kind of bands could be worldwide, you know, could have worldwide hits. Yeah.
《Money for Nothing》，是的。这完全是关于我们的空洞，我们是空洞的。是的，但里面真正能说服你们的那句歌词是：“我想要我的MTV”。是的，是的，是的。我们请了斯汀（Sting）来唱，在那些日子里，你知道，那种乐队可以是全球性的，你知道，可以拥有全球热门单曲。是的。
And wherever I would go, because we took MTV around the world, people would know about us through that song. Wow. MTV had been preceded by money for nothing. So Mark Knopfler gave us the greatest of gifts. It was unreal, like that idea that, like, he did this thing, and then, but it became like the, almost the rallying cry. And you guys also got that very line.
无论我走到哪里，因为我们将MTV带到了世界各地，人们通过那首歌认识了我们。哇。MTV在这首歌之前就已经存在了，但《Money for Nothing》让马克·诺弗勒给了我们最棒的礼物。这太不可思议了，就像那种想法，他做了这件事，然后，但这变成了，几乎成了战斗的号角。你们也得到了那句台词。
You guys, I mean, you and your whole team at various points got different artists. to scream out, I want my MTV on camera. And that was your... Oh, yeah. Yeah, because the cable companies didn't like us and didn't want to put us on. And these were older guys. They didn't get it.
你们，我的意思是，你和你的整个团队在不同的时候让不同的艺术家在镜头前大喊“我想要我的MTV”。那是你们的……哦，是的。是的，因为有线电视公司不喜欢我们，不想把我们放上去。这些都是老一辈人。他们不理解。
And they didn't want to pay. We were just somebody who was going to cut into their margins. So we knew that wherever we were, and for the first couple of years, we were only like in these towns in the Midwest, like Tulsa. People loved us.
而且他们不想付钱。我们只是会侵蚀他们利润率的人。所以我们知道，无论我们在哪里，在头几年里，我们只在美洲中部的这些小镇里，比如塔尔萨（Tulsa）。人们非常喜欢我们。
They couldn't believe it. But no one in New York or L.A. had it and never even seen it. So we knew if we could... get people, these people to call their cable companies and demand their MTV. He could eventually force these people to put us on and that really worked.
他们简直不敢相信。但纽约或洛杉矶没有人拥有它，甚至都没见过它。所以我们知道，如果我们能……让人们，让这些人打电话给他们的有线电视公司并要求提供MTV。他最终可以迫使这些人把我们放上去，这真的很奏效。
That's cool. With videos now having kind of cycled, I mean, they still sort of exist, but my God, you guys, you birthed it and it cycled into, like, just such a phenomenon, the whole, the addition of videos to the whole music industry.
这很酷。随着录影带现在经历了一个周期，我的意思是，它们仍然某种程度上存在着，但天哪，你们，你们催生了它，它经历了一个周期，变成了一个如此巨大的现象，整个音乐产业加入了录影带。
And now it's sort of settled into a place of sort of a side car kind of thing. What do you feel that the music video, has, has, what positive of it has remained in the music industry? Has it been additive? Yeah, you know, music videos are still popular. They don't only exist on MTV. That's become sort of a reality show channel.
而现在它已经沉淀下来，变成了一种类似副驾驶座的东西。你觉得音乐录影带，有什么，有什么积极的部分保留在了音乐产业中？它是起到了增益效果吗？是的，你知道，音乐录影带依然很受欢迎。它们不只存在于MTV上。那已经变成了某种真人秀频道。
And they make as many music videos today as they used to. A lot of them are made more economically. But, you know, they don't, you can get them all on the Internet on YouTube or on. Vivo, and you get them on demand, so you don't have to sit around watching some channel to wait to see Nirvana, you can just click on it and watch it right away. So that sort of killed the MTV linear network model.
他们今天制作的音乐录影带和过去一样多。其中很多制作得更经济。但是，你知道，它们没有，你可以在互联网上的YouTube或Vevo上获取它们，你可以点播它们，所以你不必坐在那里看某个频道等著看涅槃乐队（Nirvana），你可以直接点击它并立即观看。所以这在某种程度上扼杀了MTV的线性网络模式。
You guys would, at the end of every video, you'd put the name of the song, the album, the band, and the director. Yeah. And you guys launched a bunch of really incredible directors into the film industry. Yeah, you know, there was a whole bunch And there was a whole issue after a couple of years,
你们会在每个视频结束时，打上歌曲名称、专辑、乐队和导演的名字。是的。而且你们将一大批非常了不起的导演送进了电影行业。是的，你知道，有一大批。几年后出现了一个问题，
the director said, hey, how come our names aren't on there? We want to get some credit. Yeah, David Fincher, too. David Fincher was a great, Russell Mulcahy. There was Spike Jones. I mean, lots of people came up that way. When you, when the, I just, we'll talk about MTV ending in just a minute, but the initial, like the launch, the logo of the rocket taking off,
导演们说，嘿，为什么我们的名字没有在上面？我们想要一些署名。是的，大卫·芬奇（David Fincher）也是。大卫·芬奇是一位伟大的导演，拉塞尔·穆卡希（Russell Mulcahy）。还有斯派克·琼斯（Spike Jones）。我的意思是，很多人都是那样崭露头角的。当，当，我只是，我们一会儿再谈MTV的结束，但最初的，比如发布，火箭升空的标志，
is that, that was the first image ever, Right? Yes. Of MTV. And was that just what it is, which is like we're launching a new show? Well, we didn't have any money, and we realized that all this NASA footage was public domain. So we could rip off NASA and man's greatest moment and kind of make it our own. Yeah, yeah.
那是，那是MTV的有史以来的第一个画面，对吧？是的。MTV的。那只是它本来的样子，也就是我们要推出一个新节目？好吧，我们没有钱，我们意识到所有这些美国宇航局（NASA）的镜头都是公共领域。所以我们可以盗用NASA和人类最伟大的时刻，并将其变成我们自己的。是的，所以我们免费得到了它。
So we got it for free. Oh, that's great. And the logo that everybody loved them became iconic. We got that for $1,000 from some prize town. Wow. And it was sort of kind of, you guys were I'm sure we're kind of tongue-in-cheek, how grandiose this whole thing is going to be, we're putting our flag on the moon
哦，那太棒了。每个人都喜欢的标志后来成为了标志性的。我们是从某个小镇的奖品那里花1000美元买来的。哇。这有点像，我确信你们有点半开玩笑，这一切会有多宏大，我们要把我们的旗帜插在月球上，
and, yeah, here comes something cute, right. So we're going to rip off man's greatest moment, and this is going to put our flag there. That's amazing. Tom, what was the moment that you guys realized that you had really broken through? I mean, there were so many, I remember as a kid, you know, there were like, like the, when the thriller video hit,
然后，是的，可爱的东西来了，对吧。所以我们要盗用人类最伟大的时刻，我们要把我们的旗帜插在那里。这太惊人了。汤姆，你们是什么时候意识到自己真正取得突破的？我的意思是，有那么多时刻，我记得作为一个孩子，你知道，有很多，比如，当《颤栗》（Thriller）的录影带轰动时，
it was just everywhere. It was like so. Top of the hour, every hour. Was there a moment for you where you went like, Holy shit, we really got something here. We're shifting culture. Yeah, it was a slow build. You know, it took us a while to get to New York and L.A.
它无处不在。就像是。每个小时的整点。有没有哪个时刻让你觉得，天哪，我们真的搞出名堂了。我们正在改变文化。是的，这是一个缓慢的积累过程。你知道，我们花了很长时间才进入纽约和洛杉矶，
where people could see us and then they could talk about us in the media. But then, I mean, two things. One was thriller, Michael Jackson, and beat it, you know. And people say, oh, big artists are making videos with big production budgets, and they're irresistible. And John Landis directing that. And the second thing was Live Aid. Yeah.
人们可以在那里看到我们，然后他们可以在媒体上谈论我们。但是，我的意思是，有两件事。一个是《颤栗》，迈克尔·杰克逊（Michael Jackson），还有《Beat It》，你知道。人们说，哦，大艺术家们正在用巨额制作预算制作音乐录影带，它们是不可抗拒的。而且是由约翰·兰迪斯（John Landis）执导的。第二件事是“现场援助”（Live Aid）。
Oh, yeah. Live Aid. You know, ABC said, we'll run Bob Geldof came to. ABC said, we'll run three hours of it, sort of a highlight show. We said, hey, man, we'll run the whole thing for 16 hours. We got nothing else to do. So it was like the biggest show ever, and that really, really legitimized us. Wow.
哦，对。拯救生命演唱会。当时ABC说，我们要播……鲍勃·格尔多夫来的时候，ABC说，我们可以播三个小时，算是一个精彩集锦秀。我们说，嘿，老兄，我们可以把整整16小时全播了。反正我们也没别的事可做。所以这就成了史上最大的演出，这真的、真的让我们名正言顺了。哇。
Yeah, there was nowhere else to see your favorite artist, really, unless you bought a ticket to a concert. It was the only channel that you could see these people. And the VJs were cool, too. I remember like Mark Goodman and Martha Quinn. Martha Quinn. You know, people forget, but for its day, it wasn't like a flying car stuff or anything, but MTV really was revolutionary. It was a whole new visual language for people.
对，当时除了买演唱会门票，真的没别的地方能看到你最喜欢的艺术家了。这是唯一一个你能看到这些人的频道。而且那些VJ也很酷。我记得像马克·古德曼和玛莎·奎恩。玛莎·奎恩。你知道，人们都忘了，但在那个时代，虽然算不上什么飞车之类的科幻玩意儿，但MTV确实具有革命性。它为人们创造了一种全新的视觉语言。
Of course, we've gone so far past that now, but it was sort of a groundbreakinger in that way. Did you guys end up having all these, you got to know a lot of artists, too, through this, through this. I mean, at first you guys were trying to launch and get them to do stuff, and then there must have been the tipping point where they're just coming at you and all the artists are whining and dining you guys, sending you Rolexes and stuff? I didn't get any Rolexes. Yeah, okay.
当然，我们现在已经远远超越了那个时代，但在当时它算是一个开创性的先驱。你们最后是不是通过这个结识了所有这些……通过这个了解了很多艺术家？我的意思是，一开始你们是在努力起步，让他们来做各种事情，然后肯定到了一个转折点，他们开始主动找上门，所有艺术家都来对你们大献殷勤、请客吃饭，还送你们劳力士什么的？我可没收到什么劳力士。好吧，好吧。
I got a time X. No, but, I mean, it was true. We used to get like four or five videos a week, then we were getting 50 or 60, and so there was record companies set up whole departments just to service MTV. Yeah, I'll bet you guys were a real bell of the ball. All these record label heads were probably,
我只收到了一个天美时。不过，我是说，真的。我们以前每周大概收到四五支音乐录影带，后来变成了50或60支，所以唱片公司专门成立了整个部门来为MTV服务。是的，我敢肯定你们当时绝对是众星捧月。所有这些唱片公司的负责人可能都在……
working you guys like they used to work radio stations right where they would ask for certain placement of certain videos at certain days and times maybe yeah yeah it was uh we were the biggest radio station in the nation yeah right and it didn't always bring out the best in some of the people at mtv you know when you had that kind of sure power and and what did you think or feel when just recently they announced it's no longer right well they announced that in the UK for a bunch of channels that just play music videos and the MTV channel it just plays reality shows you know which really bugs me but whatever that's still there but you know it needed to die at death because it can't exist really and be a business if it when you're competing with all these
像以前对付广播电台那样对待你们，对吧？他们会要求在特定的日子和时间播放特定的MV，也许吧。是的，我们当时就是全美最大的广播电台。没错。而且这并不总能激起MTV某些人最好的一面，你知道，当你拥有那种绝对权力的时候。当最近他们宣布它不复存在时，你作何感想？嗯，他们在英国宣布了这一点，针对的是一堆只播音乐录影带的频道，而MTV频道现在只播真人秀节目，你知道，这真的让我很烦恼，但无所谓，它还在那里。不过，你知道，它确实需要走向消亡，因为它无法真正存在并作为一个商业实体运营，当你面临着……
videos on the internet and it's not like you have exclusive videos that the people that the internet doesn't have I mean there's no business there it's not going to grow. I do think that the new the Ellisons and Paramount have a chance to really reimagine what MTV could be digitally and figure out a way to put together something more interesting
互联网上所有这些MV的竞争时，而且又不是说你有什么互联网上没有的独家MV，我是说，那里根本没有商业空间，它是不可能发展的。我确实认为，新的埃里森家族和派拉蒙有机会真正重新构想MTV在数字化方面的无限可能，并想办法拼凑出一些比现在更有趣的东西。
than's out there now, which is a lot of sort of siloed, algorithm-driven. Yeah, well, those fast channels, if you want a fast channel, you could just pick your favorite artist like Taylor Swift and just click on her and just watch all her videos. Oh, there's stuff in one-stop shopping.
而不是现在这种充满孤岛效应、由算法驱动的东西。嗯，那些快速频道，如果你想要一个快速频道，你大可以挑选你最喜欢的艺术家，比如泰勒·斯威夫特，直接点击她，观看她的所有MV。哦，这简直是一站式购齐。
So, speaking of which, so you're at MTV, and then you guys decide to, then you have a bunch of other things that I mentioned in the intro, Nickelodeon, VH1, and Comedy Central, and this is great. So Comedy Central ends up becoming this huge thing, but the way it started was kind of in response to what somebody else was doing. I love this story. Walk us through that a little bit, how Comedy Central came to be. I was having a staff meeting one day and someone slips me a piece of paper to say that HBO's just announced they're going to do a comedy channel they're going to call it the comedy channel
所以，说到这里，你在MTV工作，然后你们决定，接着你们推出了我在开场白里提到的一堆其他东西——尼克国际儿童频道、VH1和喜剧中心，这太棒了。所以喜剧中心最终变成了这样一个庞然大物，但它起步的方式某种程度上是对其他人做法的回应。我太喜欢这个故事了。给我们简单讲讲喜剧中心是怎么诞生的吧。有一天我正在开员工大会，有人塞给我一张纸条，说HBO刚刚宣布他们要做一个喜剧频道，他们打算叫它喜剧频道。
and we went oh wow they're getting into our business they were the pay TV people we were like the little low rent basic people we said well that means they're going to get in our business they have a lot of money they have all these do all these big stand-up shows with Robin Williams and everything
然后我们心想，哦哇，他们要进军我们的业务了。他们是收费电视的人，而我们就像是低端的基础电视人。我们说，这意味着他们要抢我们的生意了，他们很有钱，他们能和罗宾·威廉姆斯等人一起搞所有这些大型单口喜剧秀。
what are we going to do I said well we're going to announce our own comedy channel the same day. Let's announce we're doing one too because then we'll be in every article that's ever written about that their competitors also doing a company. And you have no idea for it.
我们该怎么办？我说，好吧，我们在同一天宣布我们自己的喜剧频道。让我们也宣布我们在做一个，这样以后任何关于他们的报道中，都会提到他们的竞争对手也在做一个喜剧频道。而你当时根本连个头绪都没有。
We wouldn't have a name or anything. But we had this thing called Nick at Night and we would take like old TV shows and repurpose them and repackage them and everything. At the worst comes the worst, we can do like a version of that. But let's put our hat in the ring. And so we had a big battle with them
我们连个名字都没有，什么都没有。但我们当时有个叫“夜间尼克”的东西，我们会把老旧的电视节目拿来进行改造、重新包装什么的。最坏的情况下，我们可以做个类似的版本。但让我们先加入战局吧。所以我们和他们进行了一场大战，持续了……
for a couple of years and finally we merged. became comedy central but and they they'd because i thought if this work for them then they'd launch a movie channel a music channel and a kid's channel as well and be head-to-head competitors with a lot more money than us so so you basically started you hear our competitors are starting a comedy channel and in that moment you go let's announce it so anytime they get mentioned we get mentioned and we don't even have a product yet right and you said and you were like and i remember reading in the book you're like You said to Frank Biondi, right, who you worked with over there, and you said to him, you're like, look, it'll buy us a couple days.
好几年，最后我们合并了。变成了喜剧中心，但他们——因为我想，如果这招对他们管用，那他们接下来就会推出电影频道、音乐频道和儿童频道，成为与我们相比拥有多得多资金的针锋相对的竞争对手。所以你们基本上是一听到“我们的竞争对手正在开办一个喜剧频道”，在那一刻就决定：“让我们也宣布一个，这样只要他们被提及，我们就会被提及，哪怕我们连产品都还没有呢，对吧？”你当时还说，我记得在书里读到过，你对弗兰克·比安迪——也就是你在那边一起共事的人——说了，你对他说，听着，这能为我们争取到几天时间。
And then by the time we have to make the actual announcement, we'll have time to come up with a name and what we're going to do. Is that true? Yeah, he was, well, I put him on the speaker phone to my staff, and he says, yeah, because he had been, he had left HBO and he did not have a great relationship with Michael Fuchs, who said he was like the king of this was his baby. So Frank was all in, you know, fighting like tooth and nail against... We were like a guerrilla operation, fighting against HBO. And I think HBO couldn't believe, you know, that we did as well as we did. It was all in smoke and mirrors. And so when did you come up with the name?
然后等我们不得不正式发布公告时，我们就有时间想出一个名字和我们要做的内容了。是这样吗？是的，他当时——嗯，我把他的免提电话连到了我的员工面前，他说，对，因为他之前离开过HBO，而且他和迈克尔·福克斯的关系不太好，迈克尔·福克斯把这个当作他的命根子、他的宝贝。所以弗兰克全力以赴，你知道的，像拼命三郎一样对抗……我们就像一支游击队，在对抗HBO。而且我认为HBO简直不敢相信，你知道的，我们能做得这么好。这完全是虚张声势。那么你们是什么时候想出这个名字的？
How did you come up with programming and the whole thing for the channel? Well, initially we called it like the two days later was we called it Ha, the TV comedy channel. It was hot in an exclamation point. Sure. You know, and we had a great logo. And it was TV comedy because what they were doing was just, they were in a ripped, like, funny scenes out of, you know, TV shows and movies and some stand-up guys in front of brick walls and just put them together
你们是怎么为这个频道想出节目编排和整套方案的？嗯，最初我们叫它——在两天后，我们叫它“Ha，电视喜剧频道”。“Ha”带一个感叹号。当然。你知道的，我们有一个很棒的标志。这就是电视喜剧，因为他们当时做的只是从电视节目和电影里剪辑一些搞笑片段，还有一些站在砖墙前的单口喜剧演员，然后把它们拼凑在一起，
when they'd have, like, their equivalent of VJs. It would be like an MTV model. But, you know, we didn't think that would work. We actually had tried that once. So we thought, well, we'll just run comedy shows. So I did things that create headlines. I hired Fred Silverman, who programmed all the big networks at one time. We did deals with, like, Brian Grazer, and, you know, we licensed stuff from Norman Lear.
他们会有相当于VJ的角色。这会是一个MTV模式。但是，你知道，我们觉得这行不通。我们其实尝试过一次。所以我们想，好吧，我们就直接播放喜剧节目好了。于是我做了一些能制造头条新闻的事。我雇了弗雷德·西尔弗曼，他曾一度为所有大电视网规划节目。我们和布赖恩·格雷泽做了交易，你知道的，我们还从诺曼·利尔那里买下了版权。
And we just would continue to throw out announcements. So we got Saturday Night Live, the original five years of that, you know, 75 to 80. And we built up a, you know, a decent show. And then when we merged, you know, we had to come up with the name, us and HBO, and Comedy Central was the name. And then the turning point for Comedy Central in your book that you describe is what really set you guys off was when you hired John Stewart.
我们只是不断地发布公告。于是我们拿下了《周六夜现场》最初的五年（75年到80年），我们打造了一个……像样的节目。然后当我们合并时，你知道的，我们和HBO必须想出一个名字，喜剧中心就是这个名字。然后，你书里描述的喜剧中心真正的转折点，真正让你们起飞的是你们雇用了乔恩·斯图尔特。
Is that right? We had hired John Stewart before he had been... He was on MTV in the late 80s, early 90s. He had a show called The John Stewart Show. Yeah, I remember it. It ran for a while. So John was sort of in the stable. We never found him.
是这样吗？我们在乔恩·斯图尔特成名之前就雇用了他……他在80年代末90年代初就在MTV工作。他有一个节目叫《乔恩·斯图尔特秀》。是的，我记得。它播了一段时间。所以乔恩算是我们团队的人。我们从来没发现他。
And we actually had a guy named Craig Clairborne on the Daily Show first, who was... different type of guy and then we replaced him with John Stewart and John's vision was look let's let's just not do pop culture stuff why don't we take a crack at the news
而且我们其实最开始在《每日秀》用的是一个叫克雷格·克莱尔伯恩的人，他是一个……不同类型的人，然后我们用乔恩·斯图尔特替换了他。乔恩的愿景是：听着，我们别去搞什么流行文化的东西了，我们为什么不尝试一下新闻呢？
I'll be a fake newsman and he got his voice doing that and just got better and better I just watched a you know he's on every Monday night again still he's so brilliant he should run for president but we had what came out of that was we had John Stewart Stephen Colbert John Oliver
我来当一个假新闻主播。他通过这种方式找到了自己的风格，并且越做越好。我刚看了一个……你知道他现在每周一晚上又开始主持了，他太才华横溢了，他应该去竞选总统。不过，由此诞生的是，我们拥有了乔恩·斯图尔特、斯蒂芬·科尔伯特、约翰·奥利弗、
Samantha B Bill Maher was on our channel first, Dave Chappelle. I mean, it was a good launching place for young talent. Jimmy Kimmel had The Man Show. You may remember that. Yeah, I remember that. I mean, Tom, you think about, you name these people, all these people, musical artists, comedic voices, brilliant voices, who came up under sort of the umbrella of stuff that you did. Do you ever, do you get a little satisfaction when you watch people now, all these years later, like, yeah, I was right about all of them.
萨曼莎·比，比尔·马尔最初也是我们台的，还有戴夫·查佩尔。我的意思是，这里是年轻才俊绝佳的孵化地。吉米·坎摩尔有《男人秀》。你可能还记得。对，我记得。我的意思是，汤姆，你想想，你列举了这些人，所有这些音乐人、喜剧人才、才华横溢的声音，都是在你的庇护下成长起来的。当多年后的今天，你看着这些人时，你会不会有一点点满足感，心想：“没错，我当初看人真准。”
this. Yeah, and in truth, I didn't, I didn't, I wasn't the person who, like, picked everybody. But we had a great team there. And we were always looking for edgy, new talent that was coming up and get them, you know, get them young. And then they'd leave us. Like, Bill Maher was on politically incorrect. And then ABC hired him, and then they fired him, and he ended up at HBO.
这……是的，说实话，我并不是那个挑选了所有人的人。但我们在那里有一个伟大的团队。我们一直在寻找那些崭露头角的、前卫的新人才，把他们招揽过来，趁他们还年轻。然后他们就会离开我们。比如比尔·马尔曾在《政治不正确》节目中露面，后来ABC雇用了他，然后又解雇了他，最后他去了HBO。
And his show now is spectacular. And so you see now the front line of people who were sort of like the resistance almost politically. it's all these comedians and they all so many of them had their roots with us although they have been in other places for a while cobert kimmel mar and so on and steve korel too and korel yeah yeah go ahead no go ahead well i was going to say so then because i want to get into all the one stuff you know god we don't have enough time for everything time your life is too full so you you while you're at viacom you become CEO of viacom all ultimately, and you work for a guy called Sumner Redstone,
他现在的节目精彩绝伦。所以你现在可以看到，那些在政治上几乎成为某种抵抗力量的前线人物，全都是这些喜剧演员，而且他们当中有那么多人的根基都在我们这里，尽管他们在其他地方待过一段时间——科尔伯特、坎摩尔、马尔等等，还有史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，还有卡瑞尔。是的，是的，你接着说。不，你请说。嗯，我是想说，因为我想聊聊其他所有的事情，天哪，我们没有足够的时间涵盖所有事，你的生活太丰富了。所以你在维亚康姆期间，最终成为了维亚康姆的首席执行官，而你的上司是一个叫萨姆纳·雷石东的人，
which was, he was a difficult boss to serve. Is that a good way to put it? That's very fair, yes. He fired every CEO, including me. Including you. And so you knew, so he hires you CEO, and that means what? That means your days are numbered, basically. How long till I get fired?
他是一个很难伺候的老板。这么说贴切吗？这非常公允，是的。他解雇了每一位首席执行官，包括我。连你也包括在内。所以你心知肚明——他聘请你当首席执行官，这意味着什么？这意味着你的日子屈指可数了，基本上是这样。我还要多久才会被解雇？
But the thing is, he always liked to fire people on holiday weekends. like he fired Frank Biondi on the 4th of July, he fired Mel Carmas in, like on the Memorial Day, and I got it on Labor Day. So if you could make it through the summer season, pretty much you had another year of good times ahead. Wow. And one of the reasons, one of the things that, I know there were a lot of issue, and you talk about it in the book, but you and I have talked about this before, it's widely known, there was a thing called one of the first social media sites out there was a thing called MySpace. and it was up for grabs.
但问题是，他总是喜欢在节假日周末解雇人。比如他在7月4日独立日解雇了弗兰克·比安迪，在阵亡将士纪念日解雇了梅尔·卡马斯，而我则是在劳动节被解雇的。所以如果你能挺过夏天，基本上你未来的一年还能过一段好日子。哇。而其中的原因之一，我知道有很多问题，你在书里也谈到了，但你和我以前讨论过，这是众所周知的，当时有一个早期社交媒体网站叫MySpace，
And he wanted it. I'm still on it. I'm still on it. It's his main source of communication. So he wanted MySpace, and so did News Corp. Right? Is that fair? Sunder had never heard of MySpace.
它当时待价而沽。而他想要它。我还挂在上面呢。我还挂在上面呢。那是他主要的沟通渠道。所以他想要MySpace，新闻集团也想要。对吧？这样说没问题吧？萨姆纳以前从未听说过MySpace。
He didn't hear about it until he found out that Rupert bought it. And then he found out we'd been kicking the tires. And we never made a bid to buy it. but Rupert bought it and he went on the covers of all these trade magazines as the new media visionary and that really annoyed Sumner
他直到听说默多克买下了它才听说这东西。然后他发现我们其实一直在观望、盘算。而我们从未出价收购它。但默多克买下了它，并登上了各大商业杂志的封面，被称为新媒体梦想家，这真的惹恼了萨姆纳。
and he bought it for $560 million I'll just say ultimately Rupert sold it for $30 million Wow I'm still waiting for a thank you note that was a reason he one of the reasons he cited for firing me and right one of the reasons
他以5.6亿美元买下了它。我只能说，鲁珀特最终以3000万美元把它卖了。哇。我还在等一封感谢信呢。那成了他解雇我的原因之一，没错，其中一个原因。
which is you did him such a favor and the other thing was you early on saw the power, the potential maybe of YouTube. Is that true? Yeah. YouTube kind of took away
也就是你帮了他这么大一个忙。另一件事是，你很早就看到了YouTube的力量，或许还有它的潜力。是这样的吗？是的。YouTube最终有点像是……
all of MTV's mojo, ultimately. I mean, who could have imagined what YouTube's become today? If you check out, like, YouTube TV and everything, it's amazing. And it's been around forever,
夺走了MTV所有的灵气。我的意思是，谁能想象得到YouTube今天会变成这个样子？如果你去看看YouTube TV以及其他那些东西，太惊人了。而且它已经存在了那么久，
and they still say it's the, quote, future. But how would you... If an alien landed on the earth and you're trying to explain what YouTube is or was in its inception. How would you describe it? Is it just a free sort of destination for user-generated videos? You'd just kind of upload anything you want,
人们依然说它是所谓的“未来”。但是你会如何……如果一个外星人降临地球，而你正试图向他解释YouTube是什么，或者它在创立之初是什么。你会怎么描述它？它只是一个供用户生成视频的免费目的地吗？你想上传什么就可以上传什么，
and it's just a gathering place for all that. Is that what YouTube really is? That's what it was initially, and that was like 2005. They launched it, and it was initially anybody could upload anything and kids could comment on it. You could send stuff. It was a form of social media, person to person. And that was a whole new idea.
它只是所有这些内容的一个聚集地。YouTube真正的本质是这样的吗？它最初就是这样的，那是在2005年左右。他们推出了它，最初任何人都可以上传任何东西，孩子们可以在上面评论。你可以发送内容。它是一种人与人之间的社交媒体形式。这是一个全新概念。
And then, like, SNL would put up, like, some stuff, like, with Andy Sandberg. I'm trying to think some of... They would... Media companies would use it as sort of a promotional vehicle. So they started to get more promotional content on there. And then they've just... And did you want to buy it? Did you saw...
然后，比如《周六夜现场》会上传一些内容，比如安迪·萨姆伯格的节目。我想想还有什么……他们会……媒体公司会把它用作一种宣传工具。所以他们开始在上面获得更多宣传性质的内容。然后他们就不断地……你当时想买下它吗？你看到了……
We thought this is a whole new thing. And the world is going in this, you know, we had the TV revolution, now we got this digital revolution. And this digital revolution, this social media thing where people can communicate directly with each other. And people like us aren't gatekeepers anymore. You know, we thought, how do we get in on this? You know, you've got to own a platform. And we made a, I wanted to make a bid on it. But it was difficult for a company like us.
我们觉得这是一个全新的事物。世界正在朝着这个方向发展，你知道的，我们经历过了电视革命，现在我们迎来了数字革命。而这场数字革命，这种社交媒体的东西，人们可以直接相互交流。像我们这样的人不再是把关人了。你知道，我们当时在想，我们怎么才能分一杯羹呢？你必须拥有一个平台。我当时想对它出价收购。但对于我们这样的公司来说很难。
I mean, ultimately Google bought it for 1.6. billion the biocom board thought it was a copyright infringement machine it would make us liable for lots of lawsuits and they ultimately after i left they sued them for a billion dollars and lost 10 years later but no one could have imagined what youtube was able to morph into right you know which is but you did see you did see that there was the the the potential even though you didn't know exactly what it would become imagine how different the world would have looked had viacom purchased I mean, for $1.6 billion is right now the deal of the century? They're worth almost $600 billion here, too.
我的意思是，最终谷歌以16亿美元买下了它。维亚康姆的董事会认为它是一个侵权机器，这会让我们承担大量的官司。在我离开后，他们最终起诉谷歌索赔10亿美元，并在10年后败诉。但没有人能想象到YouTube能够演变成什么样，对吧？你知道的，不过你确实看到了，你确实看到了它的潜力，尽管你当时并不知道它究竟会变成什么样。想象一下，如果维亚康姆收购了它，世界将会是多么不同。我的意思是，用16亿美元买下它，现在看来是不是世纪大交易？他们的市值在这里也快达到6000亿美元了。
Wow, that's unbelievable. I mean, I could buy all the media companies a couple times over. Wow. And then... $600 billion. On the side of that, you also helped these guys start Vice Media as well, right? You were instrumental in getting... I work with Vice for a bunch of years, yeah.
哇，这太不可思议了。我的意思是，我可以把所有媒体公司买下好几遍。哇。然后……6000亿美元。在此之外，你还帮这些人创办了Vice传媒，对吧？你在促成……我在Vice工作过好几年，是的。
Yeah, that was a wild ride. Yeah. That's another book. That was a lot of fun, too, though. Yeah. And it crashed. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's still around, though, isn't it?
对，那是一段疯狂的经历。是的。那是另一本书了。不过那也挺好玩的。对。然后它崩盘了。对，对，对。不过它现在还在，不是吗？
No? It's barely around. They have a little studio operation. You know, they kind of imploded a bit. You know, they had a great run when they had that HBO series on that really kind of made them famous. They had a whole suite of YouTube channels. Does any, after all of these successes, does any part of you still want to be involved in media? You know, I'm happy now.
没有吗？它几乎不存在了。他们有一个小型的工作室业务。你知道的，他们有点内爆了。你知道，当他们拥有那个HBO系列节目时，他们曾有过一段辉煌的时期，那部剧真的让他们成名了。他们有一整套YouTube频道。在经历了所有这些成功之后，你的内心深处是否还有任何一部分想要涉足媒体？你知道的，我现在很开心。
I'm not in it. I mean, it's really, it seems like a lot of the funds been taken out of it, a lot of the money's been taken out. You look at these companies that are sort of stripped down and are forced to consolidate. You know, I came up, it was a more optimistic time. Things were moving in an upward direction, you know. Things were ascendant. Now it's like, you know, well, I have to tell you guys, you're all in Hollywood. You know, what the situation was coming in.
我不在那个圈子里了。我的意思是，真的，感觉很多乐趣已经被抽离了，很多资金被抽离了。你看看这些被迫精简并进行整合的公司。你知道，我成长的时候，那是一个更乐观的时代。事情都在朝上发展，你知道的。事物都在上升期。现在感觉就像是……嗯，我得告诉你们伙计们，你们都在好莱坞。你知道刚进来时的局势是什么样的。
Barely, Tom. Yeah. Yeah. we'll be right back and now back to the show it does seem like though that we are at a bit of an inflection point that's not too dissimilar from uh sort of the the launch of something like a youtube where um were it not for the invention of the internet and then the personal communication device you know those two things together were the necessary components that make up a YouTube.
勉强算吧，汤姆。对。我们马上回来，现在回到节目中。不过，感觉我们确实正处于一个拐点，这跟……比如像YouTube的诞生并没有太大的不同。若不是互联网的发明，再加上个人通信设备，你知道，这两者结合在一起，才构成了YouTube必不可少的组成部分。
Now we've got something similar, perhaps, in AI and its ability to be transformative and create these new platforms or entertainment options or we have no idea about. Some ideas are scary. Some ideas are interesting. But maybe we're at another kind of launch moment. I'm sure you've done,
现在我们可能也有了类似的东西，那就是人工智能及其变革性能力，以及它创造这些新平台或娱乐选项的能力，而这些是我们完全无法想象的。有些想法令人恐惧。有些想法很有趣。但也许我们正处于另一个启动的时刻。我确信你读过……
I'm sure you read very interesting books and niche articles and periodicals and things like that that does it not hold some kind of interest to you this sort of this moment of pioneering maybe? Yeah, and the whole AI thing is sort of daunting. Yeah. On one hand, you've got people saying
我确信你读过非常有趣的书籍、小众文章、期刊之类的东西，难道这种开创性的时刻对你没有某种吸引力、没有引起你的兴趣吗？是的，整个人工智能这事确实有点让人望而生畏。一方面，有些人说
that it's going to create these machines are going to kill us all. And on the other hand, it's going to open up this great new world and it's going to put, and someone else say, yeah, it's going to get put 20% unemployment on the board. But it seems like the big brains like you are really the only people that are uniquely qualified to really kind of cut through all that and say, yeah, it could be this, it could be that, but it also can be steered and can only be really properly steered by
这些机器会把我们全人类都消灭掉。另一方面，它将开启一个伟大的新世界，它会带来……还有人说，是的，它会让20%的人失业。但感觉像你这样的大脑，才是真正唯一具备独特资格去剖析这一切的人，并且说：“是的，它可能是这样，也可能是那样，但它也可以被引导，并且只能被……真正妥善地引导。”
somebody that has a combination of your creative acumen and your business acumen and your time in the industry. So are you not interested or excited to kind of grandfather's some of that in there? I'm sort of following it all this. It's not that there's not a lot of smart people involved. You know, these AI guys from, you know, you always say, well, they're from up north. And you can see the battle in Hollywood.
由兼具你的创造商业敏锐度、商业敏锐度和行业资历的人来引导。所以你难道不觉得有兴趣或兴奋，去把其中一些经验传承下去吗？我一直在关注这一切。并不是说没有很多聪明人参与其中。你知道，这些来自……人工智能的人，你总是说，嗯，他们来自北方。你也能看到好莱坞的这场斗争。
They need the media savvy, too, though. Yeah. They're not this media savvy, but, you know, they're going to create new media. Yeah, I'm curious and I'm watching. And it's, they're just, the amount of money that's being invested is just mind-boggling. But they need someone like you to steer it, though.
不过他们也需要精通媒体。是的。他们虽然没有这种媒体敏感度，但你知道的，他们会创造新媒体。是的，我很好奇，我也在观察。而且，投入的资金数额简直令人匪夷所思。但他们需要像你这样的人来掌舵啊。
You got, you know, put your hand up off the bench. Come on, get in there. Wait, Tom, Tom, speaking off the bench, if you were, if you were, if you were 26-year-old Tom Preston today, and you were just coming back from doing your being off the grid for a couple of years, and you were going to start in this world today, what would you launch? Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's a good question. Well, you know, I'd want to do something that I really liked, so I'd probably find my way somehow to the entertainment media business, you know.
你得……你知道的，举手请缨吧。来吧，加入进去。等等，汤姆，汤姆，说到请缨，如果你是……如果你是……如果你是当今26岁的汤姆·普雷斯顿，刚刚结束隐世几年的生活回到社会，准备在今天的这个世界开始闯荡，你会推出什么项目？对，对，对，这是个好问题。嗯，你知道的，我想做一些我真正喜欢的事情，所以我可能会设法进入娱乐媒体行业，你知道的。
probably there and say, well, now, I mean, to your point, it is sort of an inflection point. And you want to align yourself with someone who's smart. That's a business that's ascendant. So if you get in it and you choose the right place and they got the right plan, you're likely to be able to move up. And I don't know which place that is, but that's probably where I would gravitate. And I feel confident that they're going to figure this out somehow in a way that doesn't put everybody out of work in the entertainment business because uh but i just heard something today it's um they have a channel four in the uk has uh these newscasters that are AI generated that sound
大概会去那里，然后说，好吧，现在，就你的观点而言，这确实是一个拐点。你会想和聪明人站在同一阵线。那是一个处于上升期的行业。所以如果你进入其中，选择了正确的地方，并且他们有正确的计划，你就很有可能升职。我不知道具体是哪个地方，但那可能就是我会 gravitate（倾向）去的地方。而且我有信心，他们最终会以某种方式弄明白这一切，而不会让娱乐业里的所有人都失业——因为，不过我今天刚听到一个消息，英国第四频道有……这些由人工智能生成的主播，听起来……
exactly exactly like exactly like it could be one of you guys well it is well yeah shan's got wires coming out of them um uh well it's it sounds like you are you are you are um satisfied for sure with your accomplishments as well you should be. And so have you given yourself a chance to sit back and look at that guy who went off to India and Afghanistan and started in advertising and God is MBA and all that stuff? And have you landed at a spot that is satisfying to you given where you started, your frustrations early on.
简直一模一样，简直就像……这可能就是你们当中的某个人。好吧，确实……是的，肖恩身上都连着电线呢。好吧，听起来你……对于自己的成就，你肯定是感到满足的，你也理应如此。那么，你有没有给自己一个机会，坐下来好好看看那个曾去过印度和阿富汗、在广告业起步、拿到MBA学位等等的家伙？鉴于你的起点以及早期的挫折，你最终落脚的地方是否让你感到满意？
And it seems like you managed to create a space for yourself that combined all the things that you loved and that you were good at. Well, I kind of went full circle. I mean, if I look at my life in chapters, the chapter now I do a lot of not-for-profit work for like 18 years I've been working with Bono. I was the board chair of this thing to one campaign
看起来你设法为自己开辟了一片天地，将你热爱且擅长的所有事情完美结合。嗯，我算是兜了一个圈。我的意思是，如果我把我的生活分成各个章节，现在的这一章我做了很多非营利工作，我已经和博诺合作了大约18年。我是“同一战役”组织的董事会主席，
that really focuses on extreme poverty, infectious disease in Africa. Okay. And I find that very satisfying work. You know, we have red, you've probably familiar with some red stuff, you know, with Apple and everything. And that's interesting, keeps your arm into the private sector. But, you know, and it gives me a chance to really explore Africa a bit more, which I also enjoy. But so I'm sort of in that phase of life, I guess you could say. I'm, you know, it's not like giving back, but I enjoy this kind of work.
该组织真正专注于非洲的极端贫困和传染病问题。好的。我觉得这是非常令人满意的。你知道，我们有(RED)慈善项目，你可能对苹果和其他公司的一些(RED)产品很熟悉。这很有趣，能让你与私营部门保持联系。而且，这给了我一个进一步探索非洲的机会，我也很享受这一点。所以，我想你可以说我正处于人生的那个阶段。我……你知道，这倒不算是回馈社会，但我很享受这种工作。
And I like being an observer of what's going on. and in the media and entertainment business. Well, you also, it is giving back, and you did start, you know, you started a media company in Afghanistan, which still exists today. Yeah, I did that. I went back to Afghanistan for 10 years
而且我喜欢当一个观察者，观察媒体和娱乐界正在发生的事情。嗯，你这也是在回馈社会，而且你确实创办了……你知道，你在阿富汗创办了一家媒体公司，至今仍然存在。是的，我做过这事。我回到阿富汗呆了10年，
until the Taliban arrived and built up a TV network there, which was fascinating. Wow, that's great. And not the not-for-profit, but meaning like you did that is, it's not like that was like going to be a huge windfall. It was more, it was sort of giving back
直到塔利班到来，并在那里建立了一个电视网，这太迷人了。哇，那太棒了。而且这不仅仅是非营利，我的意思是，你这样做，并不是说它会带来巨大的经济利益。更多的是，这是一种回馈，
to a place that you, you really loved and you described the people, especially early on in the 70s when you first got there and what a wonderful place Afghanistan was. And now you've got these people who are there sort of holding the line, still doing it, right? Still broadcasting. And in that time, I remember you would take young people
回馈一个你深爱的地方，正如你所描述的那样，特别是早期在70年代你刚到那里时，阿富汗曾是一个多么美妙的地方。现在，你还有那些留在那里的坚守阵地的人，仍在坚持，对吧？仍在广播。在那段时期，我记得你会把那些
who were there who were working for the company and send them over here and do semesters working at USC media school and stuff and give them and educate them. And, I mean, that was a real thing that you did for a long time. Yeah. I mean, I never escaped my fascination with Afghanistan. And it gets a bad rap these days, admittedly.
在公司工作的年轻人送到这里来，在南加州大学媒体学院等机构度过几个学期的学习时光，并对他们进行教育。我的意思是，这是你长期以来一直在做的一件实实在在的事。是的。我的意思是，我对阿富汗的痴迷从未消退过。老实说，它现在名声不太好。
But they're wonderful people. And I was lured back there to start this TV net station, which became very powerful. And in terms, I thought it was a way to, you know, help change society, connect to Afghans to each other to the outside world for the first time for, you know, women, liberate women. Just seeing a man and a woman newscaster side by side.
但他们是很好的人。我被诱惑着回到那里创办这个电视频道，它后来变得非常有影响力。就长远来看，我认为这是一种方式，你知道的，去帮助改变社会，让阿富汗人彼此连接，与外部世界连接，这在历史上是第一次，为了解放女性。仅仅看到男女新闻主播并肩而坐，
sends a huge signal. We brought music back after the Taliban had outlawed everything, so we brought back music with the arts. And it's still running the network? Well, it's been, you know, it's been, we've now had like 250 advertisers. It was, now we're down to one.
就传达了一个巨大的信号。在塔利班取缔了一切之后，我们将音乐带了回来，我们把音乐和艺术一起带了回来。现在这个电视网还在运行吗？嗯，它一直……你知道的，我们曾经有大约250个广告商。后来，现在我们只剩一个了。
Wow. And it's energy drinks like Red Bull kind of stuff. That's what they have there because there's no alcohol. But we've now switched into doing programming for school for women. So we're doing educational programming And instead of advertisers, we're funded by people like Gates and other foundations, Malala Foundation.
哇。而且都是红牛之类的能量饮料。他们现在只有这个，因为那里禁酒。但我们现在已经转型为制作面向女性的学校节目。所以我们正在制作教育节目，没有了广告商，我们的资金来源变成了盖茨基金会等机构、马拉拉基金会。
Oh, that's great. And we are making these episodes in Afghanistan inexpensively. We have a diaspora group of Afghan educators that help develop the curriculum. And so it's just kind of keeping people employed in this very difficult time. But these programs for educating women are still, are now allowed? Yes, because we've picked sort of non-ideological subjects like mathematics, physics, things like. that. Got it.
哦，那太棒了。而且我们在阿富汗以极低的成本制作这些节目。我们有一群流亡海外的阿富汗教育工作者来帮助开发课程。所以这只是在非常困难的时期为人们提供就业岗位。但是这些教育女性的节目现在是被允许播出的吗？是的，因为我们挑选了一些非意识形态的学科，比如数学、物理，诸如此类的事情。明白了。
And so they're allowing it, yes. And there's a whole sort of digital part to it as well. It's, you know, it's just awful what's going on there. Yeah, for sure. This way, the business stays alive and you can employ 500 people. And, you know, women have basically been erased from public spaces in Afghanistan. And they're not even allowed to talk when they're in public. Yeah.
所以他们是允许的，是的。而且其中还有一整套数字化部分。你知道的，那里的情况简直糟透了。是的，确实如此。通过这种方式，业务得以存活，你还能雇用500人。而且，你知道的，女性在阿富汗基本上已经从公共空间中被抹去了。她们在公共场合甚至不被允许说话。是的。
Wow. Just awful. And so women who used to be able, in that 20-year interval, when we were there, in which we blew, but, you know, people went to school, became parliamentarians, became lawyers, became, you know, now they're just, you know, extremely depressed and at home. Man, Tom, you really, you really, you really, I know, what a life, dude, and you've, you've done it all. I mean, you do this kind of stuff, and you, you, you help start MTV, and you have a clothing company from a, and you're, and you're smuggling clothes across the network, hot, network. huh and you talk in the book you take Semner Redstone to a sex club in Thailand
哇。简直太糟了。所以那些以前能够……在我们那里的那20年间，我们曾迎来繁荣，人们去上学，成为议员、律师，你知道的，现在她们只是……你知道的，极度沮丧并待在家里面。天哪，汤姆，你真的……你真的……你知道的，多精彩的人生啊，老兄，你把什么都做过了。我的意思是，你做过这些事，你帮忙创办了MTV，你从一个地方搞服装公司，你还通过网络走私服装……网络。哈。你在书中提到，你带着萨姆纳·雷石东去了泰国的一家色情俱乐部，
which you talk about in the book which is just a create I implore you to read this book. Is that true? Yes, yes I did. That's crazy. Just give us a little taste of not too much of a taste. You don't want the full taste
你在书中谈到了这一点，这简直太疯狂了。我恳请你们去读这本书。是真的吗？是的，是的，我去了。太疯狂了。给我们尝一点点甜头就行，别尝太多。你不需要全部的细节，
but I kept telling him you've got to come to Asia. We've got MTV in India we've got it in China and Taiwan we've got in Indonesia and it's like the great market. You know, we were still really positive about how he could do in Asia. And he had never really been. And then he called me up to his office one day. And he says, you know, I've made up my mind. I'd like to finally come to Asia with you. Where do you want to go? He goes, I want to go to Bangkok. I go, we don't really have any business in Bangkok. You know, that's like one
但我一直对他说：“你必须来亚洲。我们在印度有MTV，我们在中国和台湾有MTV，我们在印度尼西亚有MTV，这是一个巨大的市场。”你知道的，我们对他在亚洲能取得的成就仍然非常乐观。但他其实从来没去过。然后有一天他把我叫到办公室，
place that there's a company there that's going to lay cable, but they haven't started yet. But he wanted to go to Bangkok. And then he told me quietly he'd like to go to some sex clubs. Oh, my God. You know, I had to go do some advance work, you know, to get him in a sex club. I wasn't really, I'd been to Bangkok before a bunch of times, but I was not an expert on the sex club front, which is quite a scene there. One of the most interesting things is that, you know, it's become, because of the Vietnam War, it's become like the commercial sex capital of the world.
对我说：“你知道吗，我下定决心了。我终于想和你一起去一趟亚洲了。你想去哪儿？”我说：“我想去曼谷。”他说：“我们在曼谷其实没有什么业务。”你知道的，那是……那里有一家公司要铺设电缆，但他们还没开始呢。但他就是想去曼谷。然后他悄悄告诉我，他想去一些色情俱乐部。天哪。你知道的，我不得不去做一些前期准备工作，好让他能进色情俱乐部。我其实……我以前去过曼谷好几次，但我绝对不是色情俱乐部领域的专家，那里的场面相当震撼。最有趣的事情之一就是，你知道的，因为越南战争，它变成了世界的商业色情之都，
then they have plane loads of Japanese and Germans men that come in to run wild in the various red light districts. And I'm thinking, wait, those were the two Hax's powers. Right. And now they're invading Bangkok. But, yeah, I took Sumner to a... I did my job as a loyal employee and shepherding him around. You had to take your boss, you described it,
然后大批大批坐着飞机来的日本和德国男人涌入各个红灯区寻欢作乐。我在想，等等，那可是当年的两个轴心国啊。而现在他们正在“入侵”曼谷。不过，是的，我带着萨姆纳去了……我尽到了一个忠诚员工的职责，带着他四处参观。你得带你的老板去——正如你所描述的那样，
and you guys go into a room, and this couple are lowered on a motorcycle, having actual sex. on the motorcycle, and you're there with your boss, and then he looks at you kind of like, we're good now, and you just let yourself out, right? Well, no, I had to take him to another club after that, but the interesting thing about that club was it was just filled with, like,
你们走进了一个房间，一对男女被吊在摩托车上，正在摩托车上实打实地进行性行为。而你和你的老板就在那里，然后他看了你一眼，意思好像是“我们现在可以了”，然后你就自己默默退出来了，对吧？哦，不，我之后还得带他去另一家俱乐部，但那家俱乐部有趣的地方在于，里面挤满了……
regular people, Thai people and everything in the... You hear this roar, and a motorcycle slowly comes down to a small Harley, and there's this couple on there, and they're naked, and they're all greased up, and they're doing it, and the guy's revving the engine. Oh, my God. And after a while, after a while, the people in the bar, the locals, they're not even looking.
普通人，泰国本地人什么的，都在……你听到一阵轰鸣声，一辆摩托车缓缓下降，是一辆小型哈雷，上面有一对男女，他们赤身裸体，浑身涂满油，正在办事，那家伙还在轰油门。天哪。过了一会儿，过了一会儿，酒吧里的人、当地人甚至连看都不看一眼。
You know, it's like, people are fornicating on a motorcycle two feet over your head. Yeah, we got it. Would you like another beer? So then they got pulled back up into the ceiling. Yeah. And then you got, I mean, you did everything you talk about,
你知道的，就像……人们在你头顶两英尺高的摩托车上交合。是的，我们懂了。你要再来杯啤酒吗？然后他们又被拉回了天花板上。然后你……我的意思是，你做的一切正如你所说，
I mean, you literally, people go like, from here to Timbuktu, you literally went to Timbuktu. I want to end on you, the time you went to the music festival. I remember when you and Jimmy were going to go, you were talking about it. And you guys, you and Jimmy Buffett went to the, this music festival, right? It's a festival in the desert
我的意思是，字面意义上，人们常说“从这里到廷巴克图”，而你真的是去到了廷巴克图。我想以你去的那个音乐节作为结束。我记得你和吉米准备去的时候，你提起过这件事。然后你们——你和吉米·巴菲特去了那个音乐节，对吧？那是撒哈拉沙漠腹地的一个音乐节。
out in the middle of the Sahara. Yeah, so how to... Like Burning Man or like... Like Burning Man with people on camels. It was like the local Toreg people would come. It would be like, oh, I love, we love West African music, so I got a few other people,
是的，所以怎么说呢……就像火人节一样，还是……就像带有骆驼的火人节。当地的图阿雷格人会来。这就像是，哦，我喜欢，我们喜欢西非音乐，所以我带了其他几个人，
Chris Blackwell, my friend Bill Flanagan. We flew to Bamako, the capital of Mali, and then we got a plane. We took the Jimmy Jet. We flew to Timbuktu, and we land in the Timbuktu airport. People, there's nothing there. There's no planes there.
克里斯·布莱克韦尔，我的朋友比尔·弗拉纳根。我们飞往马里首都巴马科，然后租了一架飞机。我们坐着“吉米号”喷气机飞到了廷巴克图，降落在廷巴克图机场。人们……那里什么也没有。那里没有飞机。
People are just running at our plane trying to sell us daggers, you know? It was like you're in the middle of nowhere. It looks like a town in the desert. And we had to drive a bunch of hours from there to get to the festival. And you had your own security with you and a driver. Talk about that. Yeah, we had one security guy from Bamako, and then we had another guy. And then when we got to Timbuktu,
人们只是朝我们的飞机跑来，试图向我们兜售匕首，你知道吗？这就好像你身处荒郊野岭。它看起来就像沙漠中的一个小镇。我们不得不从那里开车好几个小时才能到达音乐节现场。你当时有自己的安保人员和一个司机。给我们讲讲那个。是的，我们有一个来自巴马科的安保人员，然后我们还有另一个人。然后当我们到达廷巴克图时，
so we got to find a guy who knows how to get there. So we need a local guy who can find this way to the festival. So we hire this guy, and we set out one morning to go to the festival. And we're winding our way through the sand dunes and going and going. After about four or five hours, the security guy goes, stop, stop. And he gazzed the local guide and gets them out, and they start screaming each other. We don't know what's going on.
我们需要找一个知道怎么去那里的人。所以我们需要一个当地人带路去音乐节现场。于是我们雇了这个人，一天早晨我们动身前往音乐节。我们在沙丘中蜿蜒穿行，开啊开。大约四五个小时后，安保人员说：“停下，停下。”他把当地向导叫了过来，让他们下车，然后他们开始大吵大叫。我们根本不知道发生了什么。
And then he puts the guy in a headlet, takes out a gun, sticks it to his head. He says, I'm going to kill this motherfucker. Because he is taking us, we're going in the wrong direction. And he was taking us to an al-Qaeda. Al-Qaeda was kidnapping tourists in that area. And, like, there was just over the border in Mauritania there. There was the Germans that had been holding for a year. And we were on our way there.
然后他把那家伙按成锁喉姿态，掏出一支枪，抵着他的脑袋。他说：“我要杀了这个王八蛋。”因为这家伙带着我们，我们在朝错误的方向走。而他正把我们带向基地组织。基地组织当时在该地区绑架游客。而且，就像在马里边境那边的毛里塔尼亚一样，那里有被德国人扣押了一年的游客。而我们当时正走在去那里的路上。
And he said, I'm going to, and I'm a little bit buzzed, and I'm looking at this. I'm going, Jesus Christ, man. I mean, I just came out in the desert. to hear some music, and now I'm going to witness a murder, and I got a turban on my head. Jesus. So we, Jimmy said, let the guy free. We just leave him in the desert,
他说：“我要……”我当时有点喝嗨了，看着这一幕。我在想：“耶稣基督，老兄。我的意思是，我只是来沙漠里听听音乐，现在我要目睹一场谋杀，而且我还戴着头巾。天哪。”于是我们……吉米说：“放了那家伙吧。我们就把他留在沙漠里。”
and we picked up like a guy who was a hitchhiker. He had a cell phone with a Bob Marley ringtone, and that was enough. He said he knew how to get to the festival. So we put him on board, and off we went. You know, you could just watch MTV. You don't have to go across that. It's unbelievable.
然后我们顺路带了一个搭便车的路人。他有一部手机，铃声是鲍勃·马利的歌，这就足够了。他说他知道怎么去音乐节。于是我们让他上了车，然后出发了。你知道的，你其实完全可以只看MTV。你根本不必横穿那种地方。这太难以置信了。
What a life. It sounded like a good idea. Yeah. Well, good news for, if you're like me or you finish listening to this guy talk and you're envious that you have not lived a life even halfway as interesting as him. The good news is we've got a book to read about it. Yeah. So thank you for writing.
这生活真是多姿多彩。听起来是个不错的主意。对啊。好消息是，如果你像我一样，或者听完这家伙的讲述后，嫉妒他没有过上哪怕只有他一半精彩的人生，好消息是，我们有一本书可以读。对啊。所以谢谢你写了这本书。
Unplugged adventures from MTV to Timbuktu on sale as of November 18th from the great Tom Fresson. Proof that there's a big world out there. Get out into it. which is I say all the time, and boy, did you do that. Yeah. You are an inspiration to a lot of people, including me. You always have, and you're a great dude. And honestly, I read this book, just I devoured it.
《说走就走的冒险：从MTV到廷巴克图》，11月18日起由伟大的汤姆·弗雷斯顿发售。这证明了外面的世界很大。去闯闯吧。这也是我常说的，天哪，你真的做到了。对啊。你激励了很多人，包括我。你一直都是，而且你是个了不起的家伙。说实话，我读这本书时，简直是狼吞虎咽地读完的。
It's so good. So, Tom, thank you, man, for taking. This has been a long time coming. I'm so psyched that you came on today. Well, thank all of you. It's great to chat with you guys. I'm a regular fan. Yeah, nice meeting you, time.
太棒了。所以，汤姆，谢谢你，兄弟，抽出时间。这一天我们等了很久了。我很高兴你今天能来。好吧，谢谢你们大家。和你们聊天太棒了。我是你们的忠实粉丝。对啊，很高兴见到你，汤姆。
Love the podcast. Thanks so much for coming on and talking to us. Thank you. The great Tom Freston, you guys. Take care. Bye, God. Bye, Tom. Bye, Tom.
我超爱这个播客。非常感谢你来和我们聊天。谢谢。了不起的汤姆·弗雷斯顿，各位。保重。再见，天哪。再见，汤姆。再见，汤姆。
Thank you. Bye, bye, bye, pal. Wow. Boy, I'm uplifted and also depressed at the same time. Yeah, exactly how I feel. I know, I'm like, wow. You know, there was a time when like, I think I've probably told this boring story before, but, you know, when my career was, you know, in a real dry place.
谢谢。再见，再见，再见，老兄。哇。天哪，我既感到振奋，又同时感到沮丧。对啊，我正是这种感觉。我知道，我在想，哇。你知道，曾经有一段时间，我想我可能讲过这个无聊的故事，但是，你知道，当我的职业生涯处于一个真正的低谷时。
No, talk about that. I thought about going down to the Tom. Bradley Terminal here in L.A.X, the International Terminal, and just picking a destination up on the board and just... I love that. Just going there and starting over. Well, I got the wife and the kids, and, you know, it's a little awkward now. No, but you can just get up and go somewhere. It's called deserting your family now. I was like, you know, 23, 24. I was like Tom's age, and I was like, let me just start over somewhere else where fucking being on, you know, entertainment tonight isn't the end-all be-all. And so I'm certainly not...
不，谈谈那个。我曾想过去洛杉矶国际机场的汤姆·布拉德利航站楼，也就是国际航站楼，然后在公告板上随便挑一个目的地，然后……我喜欢这个。就直接去那里重新开始。好吧，我有老婆孩子，你知道的，现在这样有点尴尬。不，但你也可以直接收拾行李走人。现在这叫抛弃家庭。我当时大概23、24岁。我跟汤姆当时的年纪一样，我就想，让我去别的地方重新开始吧，在那里，上《今夜娱乐》什么的并不是人生的全部意义。所以我当然不是……
you know, bo-boo-hoo, you know, your life turned out so shitty. No, I'm very, very grateful, but, man, you listen to that. I just don't know if you, I was going to say, you can't have both, but he seems to have had both. Like, you went, he did that, he came back, and he was still a part of, you know, mainstream society. And not only that, Jay, what's cool is he took all of that, that sort of that, that wonderlust, as you described, and he took all those experiences, and he brought it into that environment, and that's what set him apart. He still sets him apart. He's like he has such a broad world view.
你知道，哭诉，你知道，你的人生变得如此糟糕。不，我非常非常感激，但是，老兄，听了那个。我只是不知道你，我本来想说，你鱼和熊掌不可兼得，但他似乎两样都得到了。就像，你去了，他做了那件事，他回来了，他依然是，你知道，主流社会的一部分。不仅如此，杰伊，酷的地方在于他把所有这些，那种，那种漫游癖，就像你所描述的，他把所有的这些经历，他把它们带入了那个环境中，这正是他与众不同的地方。他至今仍然与众不同。他就像是拥有如此广阔的世界观。
He also, like he said, 18 years of school. So then he was like, anything is, I just gotta get out. You know, like I've just been reading books for 18 years ago. And it changes what you use as your sort of baseline norms that you think that you can, and so you come back and you're affected by these experiences. And you're like, no, well, why don't we just do this? Yeah.
他也像他说的，上了18年的学。所以当时他就想，任何事，我都得离开。你知道，就像我过去18年一直在读书。这改变了你作为基本行为准则的标准，让你觉得你可以做到，所以当你回来时，你会被这些经历所影响。然后你会想，不，好吧，我们为什么不直接这样做呢？对啊。
You know, if you think about it, like he does all the stuff that maybe being out in the world, he might not have had. But then he's like, yeah, we're at MTV, we're going to start this. and we're going to start this comedy channel. It's like a drug. It's like it changes your mind. And like, oh, YouTube, let's buy that. And everybody's like, no, Tom, no.
你知道，如果你仔细想想，他做的所有事情，如果待在世俗的世界里，他可能根本不会经历。但接着他会想，好吧，我们在MTV，我们要创办这个，我们要创办这个喜剧频道。这就像毒品一样。这就像是改变了你的思维。然后，哦，YouTube，我们把它买下来吧。结果每个人都说，不，汤姆，不。
I wonder if, like, I wonder if doing it at that age, though, is much more meaningful and significant than doing it. Let's say, like, you know, maybe after Maple goes to college, you know, Amanda and I take off and we start doing all this challenge. Like, are we two set in our ways then at that age at 60 going around and like, can you really be affected as much? Well, there's one way. There's one way to find out.
我在想，如果在那个年纪去做这件事，是不是比，比如说，等梅普尔上大学之后，我和阿曼达动身开始做所有这些挑战，要更有意义、更重大呢？如果我们到了60岁那个年纪，是不是就已经墨守成规了，到处乱跑，像这样，真的还能受到那么大的触动吗？好吧，有一个办法。有一个办法可以找到答案。
Just do it. Just do it. I think, honestly. But what if it turns out? Yeah, no, it was a waste of time. You're already stuck in your ways, and now you're 70. But at least it's worth going to try to find it. And I would say, like, you hear that.
去做就是了。去做就是了。老实说，我这么觉得。但如果结果证明呢？对啊，不，那纯粹是浪费时间。你本来就已经墨守成规了，现在你已经70岁了。但至少去尝试寻找答案是值得的。而且我会说，你看，你听到了这些。
It makes me want to say to my own kids and to my younger self and to anybody if you're under 30 or 4, whatever it is, whoever you are, put your phone down and get out in the world. You know, that's kind of, it makes you just think, like, just get out there. Yeah, but don't put it down before you get a smartless mobile plan. No, no, no, switch to smartless mobile and get a good plan. Yeah, and then 10 gigs for 10 bucks.
这让我想对我自己的孩子、对我年轻时的自己、对任何人说，如果你不到30岁或40岁，无论你是谁，放下手机，走到世界中去。你知道，这就好像让你不禁去想，走出去吧。对啊，但在你拥有Smartless移动套餐之前可别放下手机。不，不，不，换到Smartless移动套餐，选个好套餐。对啊，还有10美元10G流量。
Yeah, right, but it is true. It is true, yeah. Go out and have a rich life. And Jay, you were saying to him, like, do you have this moment now looking back where you feel a sense of satisfaction? Like, yeah, he's, think of the stuff and the people he's met. Like, even now he'll be like, if you follow him on Instagram and he'll be like, you know, I'm in Albania. I mean, some like gourd, I'm talking to the prime minister and I'm doing this and that, and he's just, you know.
对，没错，但确实如此。确实如此，对。去过一个丰富的人生吧。杰伊，你刚才对他说，你现在回首往事时，会有这种满足感吗？就像，对，他，想想他经历过的事和遇到的人。就像即使到现在，他也会在Instagram上发动态说，你知道，我在阿尔巴尼亚。我是说，跟某个高官，我正在和首相交谈，我正在做这做那，而他，你知道。
I didn't even, is he married? He has a long-time partner, his, uh, Kerry, who's amazing. Yeah, okay, so he's true, he's not, he's not still going around solo bopping around. No, no, no, he's, no, but he's, uh, she's a good friend and an awesome person, uh, in her own right, just amazing. Yeah, and he's just, but he's always, he's, he's just interested. Yeah, that's, yeah, you know. Well, that's the key. You've got to stay curious and interested the whole time, right?
我甚至不知道，他结婚了吗？他有一个长期的伴侣，他的，呃，凯丽，她太棒了。对啊，好吧，所以他其实并没有，他并不是还在一个人到处瞎晃悠。不，不，不，他没有，但他的，呃，她是一个很好的朋友，本身就是一个非常了不起的人，简直太棒了。对啊，而且他一直，他只是充满好奇心。对啊，就是这样，你知道。好吧，这才是关键。你必须始终保持好奇心和兴趣，对吧？
But it seems like everybody that was around, everybody that was around us had such fun. And I had fun today with all of you. And I think a good time was had. Bye, oh, everybody. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但看起来我们身边的人，我们周围的每个人都过得那么开心。我今天和你们大家在一起也很开心。我想大家度过了一段美好的时光。再见，哦，各位。Smartless是由贝内特·巴尔比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿尔姆贾夫100%有机纯手工制作的。Smartless。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。